good morning and welcome to this joint
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
I'm Council Keith well and I'm chairing
the meeting today
may I first remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use and that you do not interrupt other
speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
and laptops are on silent
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
so attending today we have the members
of the committee here on my left we also
have offices
um including the following Philip bisbel
Chief planning officer John maudsley
professional lead digital Solutions
Gemma Walker area planning manager and
Julie have our business practice manager
in development management
and we have three Witnesses and Philip
Isbell will introduce those three
Witnesses in due course and they're here
to answer our questions on about their
pre-app planning experience
we also have Deborah Fenton director of
housing Justin King Housing needs and
standards manager
and David Weber senior environmental
health officer
and in due course we will be joined by
Fiona Duhamel director for economic
growth and climate change Michelle
Gordon corporate manager for economy and
business
and Claire free Economic Development
officer
we also have Jan Robinson corporate
manager of for Law and governance Alicia
Norman lead officer for overview of
scrutiny Bethany Webb and Claire Philpot
from democratic services department
and we have
some counselors present at present we
have
um councilor General spoon be a baby
Cabinet member for housing and Ravinia
hadtingham
mid-suffolk Cabinet member for housing
and I think I've included everybody
so can I move to the agenda please
first of all apologies for absence and
substitutions please
chair we have apologies this morning
from councilor Melanie Barrett and
councilor Simon Barrett is substituting
and we also have apologies from
councilor Caston
thank you very much
are there any Declarations of Interest
please
no Declarations of disclosable peculiar
interests
or other registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
nothing to declare thank you
can we now turn to the minutes
item three is to confirm the minutes of
the joint meeting held on the 23rd of
January 2023
are there any comments on the accuracy
of the minutes please
if not can I have a proposal that we
accept
I have a proposal from uh councilor
Osborne seconded by councilor Mueller
we will now conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that is 11 votes for
that is unanimous thank you very much
the next item is to confirm the minutes
of the baber meeting held on the 23rd of
January 2023 and I'll hand over to my
co-chair councilor John Hinton
thank you councilor Willem
um
this year for the minutes for the baber
members only
to confirm the minutes of the baber
meeting held on the 23rd of January
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes from baby
members
because I have a proposal please
a seconder
Council Osborne
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
sure that vote is now in progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
status unanimous
thank you we move on now to the minutes
of the midsummer meeting held also on
the 23rd of January 2023
these minutes are for mid-suffet members
only are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
if not can I have a proposal that the
minutes are accepted councilor Dave
Muller and councilor Terence Carter
thank you very much
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is five books for
Saturday unanimous thank you the minutes
of the mid-suffolk meeting on the 23rd
of January have been confirmed
do we have any petitions in accordance
with the council's petition screen
please
none received here thank you any
questions by the public please
thank you and any questions by
counselors
thank you
so we move on to item number nine
this is the item Jos 2245 our planning
pre-application advice customers getting
a valuable service
and I was expecting to win to invite one
of the cabinet members to introduce the
report
um
finding that can I ask
our Phillies belt pleased to introduce
the report
this is thank you Jim good morning
members um the report uh details where
our planning pre-application service has
been uh surveyed and that's been in
operation since uh 2018 we commenced the
pre-application service in its present
charged format in 2017 and we've
conducted an annual survey every year
since that time and I think members of
this committee have been made aware of
of previous survey results in previous
reports on on that and obviously the
background papers contain the latest
information around those surveys we also
included within the papers today the
results of a survey of officers officers
which we conducted this year and have
not previously run
and generally speaking
these lead I think to a conclusion on
your officer's point of view that
pre-application advice does provide a
valuable service both for officers and
for customers there are nonetheless as
you'll see from the statistical
information in the report some
qualifications to that and there is a
summary of the survey information which
is a paragraph four three uh through to
paragraph 4.4 of the report in addition
and perhaps more helpfully this morning
you have three Witnesses who are
frequent users of the pre-application
advice service they are Philip Branton
of winter kevener Architects James
Tanner of Holland's Architects and James
Platt of locus planning chairman I don't
think there's anything more that I wish
to add at this stage and I think it's
really for the the committee to take the
matter where it wishes
thank you very much
who would like to ask first questions
and they could be questions of the
officers or questions of our Witnesses
somebody must have a question
councilor Barrett I'll start off do you
think 45 satisfaction is acceptable and
where would you like to see that move to
uh
thank cancer I don't think 45 is
acceptable I'd like to see it higher
than 50 percent uh I think there is a
problem in trying to establish what
people have in their heads as to what
satisfactory is but certainly uh I would
like to see it rise above 50
and for as long as uh as long as we
continue to serve I suspect we will
always need to continue to review the
quality of the advice because the advice
is provided by officers uh their
experience and the advice that they give
or doubtless change Case by case and
need to be reviewed Case by case
thank you do you have a follow-up
question Council Barrett yeah I I um I
mean I think the overall position of
having a pre-app system is is good
it's what most councils and I think it's
required what worries me is
um and I sit on planning and I see quite
a number of applications coming
and I've had we've had two in the last
to
three planning committees where
um
the applicant has had planning
pre-advice
and being given
to zoom you the green light to put the
application and bring it to committee
only to be surprised when the committee
papers come out and there is then a
refusal
recommendation when they've been led to
believe that they were ticking all the
boxes
this has happened a number of times the
last one was uh
an application for East bergholt we also
got one which is a little bit serious
because it's coming up tomorrow or
Wednesday where those applications had
had
pre-application device
what was the reason there seems to be an
a turn of advice given
most of the time I think it seems to be
that one officer has initially started
that advice
and then another officer has then taken
over and had a change of heart
um
do you do you recognize that as a
problem
uh chairman yes I I can see that as a
problem it's been a problem as long as
I've been in in the planning system from
being a junior officer myself many many
years ago
planning is an iterative process you
gain more information as you go through
it and when you start off with the
pre-application inquiry the purpose from
my side of the table is to provide the
best advice that we reasonably can on
the information that we have
uh there are sometimes uh limitations as
to the information you're provided and
there are sometimes limitations there's
the information that you know and the
world does not stay static the policies
change sometimes stakeholders
considerations change so you are to some
degree looking at a moving Target with
some of this
um the question of the accuracy of the
advice if officer a interprets and
applies the policies to mean one thing
you would hope that the second officer
will follow that line and that's
certainly my expectation we can't and
have tried in the past to ensure that
officers if you have a principle that an
officer deals with a preamp they are
logically the person whose best place to
deal with the application follows the
volume of cases means that we haven't
always been able to do that and in terms
of the specifics because this can boiled
anti-gregate specifics this is where we
think introducing a more regular audit
approach is the right way to do this so
that we selectively look at specific
advice from officers on a more regular
basis than we presently do and look to
establish whether that is effective and
represents good advice
it doesn't always it sometimes doesn't
go to the detail of the issue and to
that extent uh you know there are
sometimes challenges in the advice given
but planning inevitably all of the
advice we give comes on without
prejudice basis
the committee process cannot be a
guarantee and I believe most people
accept across the country that preamp
advice is the best indication of where
officers are likely to go but it cannot
be a promise of an outcome
foreign
yes our Phil Branson with security
Architects so yeah just sort of picking
up on that point specifically and I'd
like to comment that generally I think
pre-ap advice is useful and proactive
with Bay brand Miss Suffolk so
um but there are a few issues that we're
having as a practice and have have in in
the past and and it's really kind of the
the change like councilor Barrett is
saying the change from the principle of
the pre-app advice at pre-app stage and
then moving forward to taking it to a
formal application and I appreciate the
consultation responses can come in and
change things and policy policies can
change but we've had several cases where
we've taken pre-op advice we followed
that pre-advised to the letter
um and it's been in quite a short period
of time so we're talking you know a six
month window from pre-app to formal
submission
um and the principle of planning
principle is change the the council's
opinion has changed quite often that
does come in you know um with a with a
different officer picking it up a
planning application stage
and to us and to her clients and the
applicants that seems extremely unfair
when you know my clients have invested
sometimes quite heavily financially in
additional reports our services external
consultant surveys all these things to
put to put formal application together
based on the pre-app advice and then we
get once we get the planning
applications submitted we're getting a
different response
um and you know I appreciate if if a
Highway's
officer hadn't been consulted at pre-app
stage and they came in and said
something I'd accept that that was
something we needed to deal with but
it's more the principle of it changing
that causes the biggest problem
um
and that's where I think
one of the big issues that we're having
with all local authorities at the moment
is communication not just with offices
but officers also communicating or not
communicating enough together so if you
had an officer that did the pre-app
um and and obviously offered that advice
to to any agent then I think it's
essential that the officer picking up
the planning application if they're
different should be talking to that
previous officer and and and
understanding why they offered that
advice and the details of it so
that's that's probably the biggest
concern that we're having when advising
clients to to run you know the pre-app
service
could I just ask
ing when do you
do you find out uh are you immediately
informed well before the the
um application goes to committee or the
report is written are you are you
informed that there has been a change of
view
um
I mean it doesn't come as a it doesn't
come as a complete shot when the papers
are printed I guess you you do learn
about it before then yeah I just wonder
how how do you learn about it
generally once a planning application is
submitted
um
we don't tend to get a feel from the
officer of where it's going until the
consultation period is finished the
first 21 days so once we've got through
that first process
um the Consultants have responded or not
responded Depending on time frame you
know depending on workload I appreciate
um then that's generally when an officer
will give us some feedback and that's
probably when it comes out
not always sometimes it is a bit later
and and again that kind of comes down to
kind of this communication issue that
we're having across the board
um with local authorities and and
planning offices
generally it's yeah it's it's probably
post that 21 day initial consultation
period
ah brilliant
I'd like to ask Philip Isabel about his
comment regarding the move from a
pre-apped to an app
when the officers change because you
know that whatever causes that situation
um because it seems to me that if
one officer gives an opinion or a piece
of advice then for whatever reason
disappears and another officer takes
over and decides that that advice is
should be different
should that not be referred up the chain
of command to say to so that that could
be challenged and before it goes back
out to the applicant because you know
clearly you're storing up a potential
conflict there
I think you're right you are storing a
potential issue
um I think the important thing is to get
the advice right first time uh and I
think that's about checking better over
the quality of what's advice so the way
free app is issued if I as an officer
write a piece of pre-application advice
that will be checked off by one of my
senior team before it's dispatched so
there is a measure of checking of that
advice but I think clearly there's
something that's not working in order to
get to the situation where as Mr
Brampton describes we have that change
in opinion I I don't agree with the
pre-app advice however I write at a
different conclusion
I don't know that there's a perfect
solution for this because there will
always be some things that matter and
sometimes this is about the skills and
experience of the junior officer who
doesn't anticipate something that a
senior officer might well foresee and
that then becomes a question of skill
experience and ability to anticipate
problems that you can't even see within
a pre-application advice
request so there's
um there's an opportunity to improve
that for sure
I think
because these cases are often so
specific that question of getting the
best out of prep advice becomes a
question of mentoring and support for
the junior officer so that and and this
is something that I and my senior team
are looking at
um so that the junior officer uh
is is better supported to develop
the thoroughness of their advice I have
in the past known situations where one
officer disagrees with another just just
as a matter of principle but these are
often cases where you can take a view
either way depending on how you want to
weight the issues but generally speaking
the purpose of a to get confidence in a
pre-application service you do need to
be able to consistently handle things so
that
more times rather than fewer your advice
is reflected in the decision that's
reached and I think you know there are
questions around this and how we achieve
that and it is something we need to to
look at
thank you
do you have a follow-up question or
thanks Joe I think not so much a
question but I think really taking the
point up that Mr Isabel has made is that
I think there needs to be more checks
and balances especially when opinion
differs
um because as the witness has pointed
out that can be quite costly from their
point of view in terms of man you know
how they process it and and take the
application forward so for me
um I think one of the one of the things
that the planning team need to do is to
ensure that there is a myth process by
which if there is a differing difference
of opinion from one officer to the next
that someone higher up the chain can if
you like adjudicate and make sure that
you know
if the opinion is different it's validly
different or if it isn't then you know
go back to square one
thank you uh councilor Dawson please
uh yes one things I needed you might be
able to clarify is on the
recommendations
um
a slightly concerned reading that at
0.33 and 3 4 is about the development of
management planning for the officers and
develop a regular audit for timeliness
ETC for the offices
and then later on in the summary it sort
of says room for improvement with the
customer services
and 3.2 of one of the recommendations is
the pre-application service is going to
be left open so it leaves me with should
we it simply concentrating on the
offices and not the customer
and is that that might be the right way
to go I'm not quite sure so that's uh
but should there not be because
otherwise what could happen here the
customer falls through the
um never really perhaps has the
opportunity
to provide or given the opportunity to
to question or perhaps have a review if
it's left open
as well
thank you
um so at the moment we've surveyed
annually and I guess we did that for a
couple of years and then realized that
actually we were at risk of losing the
people who
you know nine months ago had had pre-app
and had gone from their minds and it was
just another email from the council that
they weren't going to respond to so the
intention is to effectively make that
survey open-ended so that we can then
capture things a bit more in real time
and give them some give more immediate
it so the customer survey the the users
of this in the sense the people paying
for the the pre-app advice service would
then have a an ability to provide
feedback in real time and probably more
accurately about how their response was
to
that pre-application advice rather than
waiting you know nine six nine months
before getting a survey request so the
intention is to keep that open-ended
we've never previously surveyed officers
for their review about the value of
pre-app advice and so Our intention is
to do that on an annual basis just to
see what we learned from that and
obviously there are there are
this report about that
and you know we don't have a way we can
effectively measure the community's
response to this because clearly the
whole purpose of providing charge
pre-app is to provide something which
achieves a more effective process
achieves a more efficient handling of of
a matter so that in business terms
agents and Architects can get confidence
that something is being handled
appropriately and they know what they're
going to get the right first time idea
you know the certainty of outcome no
surprises
um so can I just does this mean the
survey will continually annually with an
open or does it mean that the actual
survey will not be
regular
so yeah as Philip has mentioned we have
surveyed the customers and
your previous year so that would be the
financial year so we usually run it in
June time looking at the previous year
April to March
so we thought that it would be better to
leave the survey open to have a link at
the bottom of the final report to say
please submit your feedback regarding
how we did and to have that continually
running throughout the year we could
then look at a sample across whichever
debts we want because those responses
will be dead Stout so instead of having
to wait until the next survey we would
then take a sample at set points
throughout the year to look at how we
are thank you thank you
thank you I wonder if one of our
Witnesses would like to comment on this
before I go on to the next uh next
member of the committee about the
the timing of you giving feedback
um
because it must come as a bit of a
out of the blue when it when it comes
eight months after you've had your
pre-app advice
so um yes if you would thank you
um yeah thanks councilwoman um
personally I would say there is that
that kind of lead into it with the
survey
um
I also find
often it's it's an extreme it's if
you've had very good service you find a
reason to comment if you've if you've
had very poor service you might find a
reason to comment
um I think the survey
to be honest
um
as an agent and I can only speak myself
but it's another thing that is a is kind
of a snapshot in time that we have to
comment on and provide some input and I
if we had more of an ease of
responding on a case-by-case basis and
so we go through that pre-app process if
there's something that is quite quick
and efficient to provide a kind of
rating or a review at the end of that
process I think that would be far more
beneficial as an agent I think it also
kind of can lead to
um dealing with each individual case
um often I think one poor case should we
say throughout the year might inform
that overall survey and give a a sort of
I suppose a very small kind of
um
insight into the whole process when
actually having an opportunity to come
on each individual case may provide a
space something that's more useful
um so yeah I I think moving away from an
annual survey and something more
relatable to each individual case that
you submit as an agent would be
preferable from my point of view anyway
thank you
um I've got Council scarf next please
picture
um yeah I mean I'm interested in the
dynamic between agents and Architects
and our planning officers it seems that
sometimes the uh information supply for
a pre-app maybe is not as full as it
should be and that's a common that's one
of the ones that's come back from the
officers so I'm interested in hearing
from both sides how much actual dialogue
in a pre-app is there backwards and
forwards do our officers actually say
well it would be useful if you'd
provided the information on X Y and Z
you haven't can you
is there is that that sort of is that
enough dialogue because it seems to me
one of the themes I'm picking up perhaps
is and I'm sure others are communication
needs to be improved all around are here
between officers and applicants between
officers and officers
Etc in order to get the best that we can
out of the system so practice you could
give us any you know example do you
think that that works well do you think
that the information that you give
um you know is is sufficient uh Etc
yeah I might pick up on that but I think
it's a very good point Canada scarf
actually
um and I think you have to understand
that you know we don't all work for huge
developers so sometimes the clients or
the applicants are you know sort of in
individuals where where you know the
cost of making an application can be
quite prohibitive so
when we start the pre-app for sort of
smaller schemes we're looking at a a to
establish the principle of whether
development is acceptable without
launching into full-scale sort of
drawings and other information that I'm
sure would be extremely useful at
pre-app but the applicant doesn't want
to pay at that point until they can
establish whether or not the principle
of development is acceptable so so we we
I'd say get away but we sort of limit
the amount of expense we have to get to
that pre-apped stage established that a
principle is acceptable and then we can
either look to add other bits to the
pre-app before we get to full submission
but is it's that sort of balance between
wanting to limit the amount of financial
exposure until you've got a sort of
established in principle yes or no and
one of the things I find that makes a
big difference in in my pre-app
experiences is actually face to face
with on-site meetings and that comes
back to Phil's Point as well that that
continuity between the assigned pre-app
officer and then the case officer is
absolutely vital because the things you
talk about and discuss on site you're
pointing at bits and pieces and having a
general discussion that's going to be
very very difficult for another officer
to pick up no matter how detailed the
conversation might be between the two
officers the effective officers is still
there of course so I think that you know
when you've had an on-site meeting
it's really vital that you have that
continuity with the same case officer
but I think it is establishing that
dialogue and if there is a piece of
Vital Information that would make the
preamp more valuable then I think the
powering officer should should ask for
it and then we can take advice back for
the applicants saying whether we're able
to provide it at that stage or not but
it's that balancing line between
spending enough to get a decision before
you then take the next step in my
experience
oh
thank you
um I've got councilor Granda next and
then councilor Ekman young and then
councilor Lindsay thank you
Casa Grande
I would like if I may um to
says
um how paper made Suffolk planning
Authority Compares with other planning
authorities that you deal with
um where
where we may be better hopefully but
we're also we could learn from your
experience with other planning
authorities what what we could we do
better that other authorities are
currently doing at this stage
are you able to give us that information
to assist us please
I suppose because my practice is based
in Hadley and has been for 40 plus years
we do a lot of work with baby Suffolk
and have historically but we do work for
other local authorities Essex and
Norfolk as as well
um
and in and in general like I said at the
start I think the pre generally the
pre-op advice we get is good you know
the Heritage pre-app advice is get we
get is good I haven't got a problem with
that I think
um picking up on points that I've
already talked about and and something
that James picked up on as well it is
that communication that that is lacking
and and I totally agree with what James
says if we were told
via a a case officer
um that an additional report would make
this much more robust response then we
could take that back to our client and
we say look let's let's invest in this
because it's going to be worth it in the
long run
um the other thing is is is is is really
you know going back to the communication
piece and
um and the um
the ability to meet face to face
I've had experience very recently where
where we had a meeting we had a meeting
set up that was going to be
um in in you know in a meeting where I'm
here at the house got an email back
there was no meeting rooms so the teams
was was
the team's invite percent through I did
respond and we have got a meeting room
now but but I think that's something
that now we've moved on from Lockdown
and covered hopefully that that the
majority of my colleagues and and and
other and other Consultants to work with
are back in the office and communication
is much better within the team the team
are learning better so I think that's a
key key point so I think that's
something that needs to be considered
and and worked on but comparing
to others I think generally like I said
your advice is is good
um we acknowledge that all local
authorities are pushed at the moment and
resourcing is tough
um but I suppose because we do a lot of
work with you guys with baber and
mid-suffolk
um we do have this problem more where
the principal advice changing with you
more or or later mid Suffolk more than
other local authorities we have pushed
back on other local authorities when a
concerte has come in and said well
actually we want to change that advice
and we've pushed back until we did
preact we paid good money for it and and
we've still got a result so I think
that's you know and I I know I'm harping
on the same point but I think that's a
key point for us
I would Echo much of that as well but I
think one of the strengths of the
Midsouth foot pre-application process is
the ability to engage with the
consultees as options as add-ons to the
pre-app advice and that does work quite
well
um for example if you do at East Suffolk
they don't have as far as I'm always
still they don't have a a formal pre-app
arrangement with the highway Authority
so it's a bit haphazard as to how you
approach
Highway pre-application device in the
Suffolk whereas mid-suffic it's a it's
an add-on it's a bolt on you pay for it
okay it's an additional cost but I don't
mind that because you get a better
response and actually you can warn the
client that it's coming and factor in as
part of the proposal to take that
pre-application route forward so I think
that quite that works quite well
um I think some of the changes in the
heart of applications often come from
the consultees it's one of our biggest
problems and Bug bears at the moment
we've got numbers of issues I think
going over the llfa in particular and at
the llfa it's the surface water flooding
issues that are particularly difficult
to get my head around at the moment so I
think it would be interesting to see how
we could explore a slightly easier route
to bring that into the pre-app process
so we can try and iron out some of those
problems easier on but I think Phil that
that consultee dealing with console tees
is part of the pre-app process
um could evolve it's not bad and it
works well and it's better than other
local authorities but I think you know
we could look at a way to perhaps evolve
that
yeah I think well firstly my background
I do submit pre-apps in Norfolk and
Suffolk so choir
um varied kind of council base that I
made submissions to
um I think I think starting with the
with the positives
um certainly I think the
the actual procedure and you know is
very slick with mid-suffic uh baby mid
Suffolk I think
um the process of submitting it via the
uh online I think that the speed at
which things have registered is is very
very good
um
the uh contact from officers
um I think you know I I tend to and I
think most value is achieved from either
um an on-site meeting and or a meeting
via teams or some sort of format as part
of the pre-app and I do find that
they're very incredibly timely over
scheduling those meetings I get a con
you know an email from an officer saying
can you suggest some dates so I think
all of that is very very
um punctual sufficient which I would say
with a lot of other local authorities
um I want to say pre-app at times seems
to be on the back burner um it seemed it
you know it's something that you you are
dealt with when there's capacity almost
which obviously if it's a paid service
which the majority of councils now that
I deal with are all charging for it that
can be kind of a bit of pill to swallow
really so um I think that's something
that that bay Midsouth do probably in my
experience I think
um better than other local authorities I
deal with
um I think the the response time is very
good
um you know I have other local
authorities where you are you know it's
confirmed you should have a written
response within four weeks and you know
10 weeks later you're still waiting for
a response so again I think that's
that's good in and officers generally if
they want an extension of time it's
usually a week maybe a couple of weeks
at most um and there's usually some sort
of
um correspondence around that to agree
that so I think they're the
the good bits
um I think
and I would say on a caveat this that
it's probably my experience with every
local Authority I've had some excellent
pre-app advice and I've had some poor
pre-app advice
um I don't think mid Suffolk in any way
um
it kind of sits anywhere on the scale of
being worse or better than other local
authorities in that sense
um so I I think where I would say the
the improvements may be made is I I
think it's sometimes that um process
where an officer makes a effective
provides advice through pre-app
and it gets to a manager for sign off
and I think somebody with the experience
that is in place here
should be able to vet that and probably
turn it back for further review and some
you know for that to be shaped a bit
more
um and often I I it feels as though the
advice had been has been administered
um
maybe too too often to to meet a certain
date
um you know and provide that punctuality
um and I think that's probably where you
know I'd suggest there's there's room to
improve is
um a secondary element that sort of vets
advice and I think obviously there's
been points today about you know
officers making a or providing advice
and that you know proceeding with
application and the the ultimate
recommendation differing from the advice
provided and I suppose I think if you
can replicate that sign off process
internally through a pre-app hopefully
with another person you know vetting
that and being a secondary kind of tier
um I think that would help improve
sometimes the quality of advice that
that comes out the door
yes thank you
um
I'll move on now to counselor Edward
young thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um well it's it's heartening to hear
from the witnesses that we are in some
respects providing quite a good service
but I think if I look at
um section 4.3
we have five years worth of results and
quite frankly they're pretty average
results
um and I suspect there is a certain
degree someone who's involved in my
professional life with seeking customer
opinion a certain degree of customer
fatigue here I would suggest with these
responses and I think one of the key
things
from reviewing
service with customers is actually what
are you going to do about it to make it
better
and and some of the things that are
being proposed would Trend in that
direction but there are no really
specific
kpis being put forward as a the level of
improvement that's going to be achieved
and I think there's a confusion between
periodic customer service
surveys and specific reviews with a
particular Customer because they have a
particular issue or they make a comment
that Warren's attention and I think some
clarity is needed from the officers in
that respect in terms of the
recommendations that we have here in
front of us today
I'm not quite sure what the question was
there cancer people is there a question
there that that you're directing towards
well I need to understand uh Mr chairman
what are the kpis that the this pre
pre-app service is going to seek to
achieve
for one and
two
what is going to be the mechanism for
actually
dealing responding to customers to
ensure them that they have made
improvements to the service
Mr as well is there something you can um
respond to
um
so firstly
3.2 we're opening the survey to view
that through the year rather than to
have that on a snapshot once a year
hopefully that will get us more
information
in real time
so I'm not sure what we can add to that
in terms of
um
in terms of a recommendation to this
Committee in terms of an annual surf I I
think the same kind of customer fatigue
would apply to planning offices if we
surveyed them ever over every case
um because you might find you'd end up
the same kind of points about this
preamp didn't provide that information
the other one did so I think you know
from my perspective an annual survey of
planning offices is enough to gain a
measure of how things are going
in terms of audit we have been
undertaking audit and uh review of the
timeliness of these things so that we
have some objectivity to it rather than
by the individuals preparing the advice
or signing them off
that is is a model that we're looking to
develop and to do that monthly at the
moment it doesn't say it in this report
but that's the intention
um and I myself would expect to get
involved in that and the insist
assistant directory is also hoping to
get involved in that but that becomes a
question of diary management and so that
question of of audit is one thing
in the middle of this though is the
quality of the advice that's provided
and the reaction to it
um
which
if you don't get the advice you like
might lead to the response that you get
in terms of this so I'm a little
cautious that responding to customer
surveys of this nature
the planning application process has to
judge applications fairly
this cannot this advice is given without
prejudice it has to be it cannot be
otherwise
and so we're always going to be stuck on
the horns of there may be things which
lead to a different result
I don't have a recommendation for
committee in terms of particular kpis
around
the the survey responses and indeed
these are a picture over a period of
years which I think is useful but in
changing the time frame in which those
surveys are undertaken will end up at a
different point
so
um
that question of what is good value is
is going to be very very personal and
subjective to the experience an
individual has and what matters to me in
providing pre-application advice most of
all is the behaviors of the officers in
delivering the advice
as you will know I know probably said in
other forums
um Bainbridge Suffolk struggles to
recruit planning officers that
experience grades and that's a
recognized Factor so therefore we are
always and have for a long time been a
training organization that does not mean
one can provide a perfect service and
one must put the energy into ensuring
that the advice given is quality and uh
is effective and to that extent I think
it's difficult for me to give you a
specific kpi as I sit here on the floor
being asked the question by uh councilor
epignon
um you know I would ideally like to be
able to put some Metric to it but I'm
not sure I can actually suggest the
metric as it as I said
something that you can think think of
after the meeting but um we could make a
recommendation that that's something
that officers considered but we can't
put you on the on the spot I do I think
the thing is I mean if you look at this
quality in government terms is entirely
about whether you agree with whether
you've agreed with government looked at
in retrospect
so this is about value but not quality
um I I think I'm interested in quality
but not in the terms that national
government is interested in so that
question of how we measure quality in a
in a statistical sense I'm given Council
weapon Young's experience I'd welcome
advice as to how to achieve that because
I think it's a difficult problem to get
to the bottom of we undertake
um a regular client-side panel that
which uh Mr Branson Mr Tanner and Mr
Platt attend and they've been very
polite about the service this morning
and that's kind of them but not
necessary from my point of view there
are there is feedback that we need and
that is one vehicle available to agents
which is nothing to do with these server
surveys we undertake that quarterly
there's a combination of things that are
available here as routes to improve
dialogue
communication I think is a behavioral
thing on the part of office is to
improve how they have dialogue with
applicants but we're also into training
because ultimately a lot of what I see
are officers who do not like delivering
bad news and if they've delivered advice
that is positive and then they realize
they've made a mistake and missed
something which does happen we are into
the territory of
how do they deal with that and this
becomes awkward and uncomfortable I
would rather that officers developed
advice which is straight
um playing and risk is gives the client
gives gives the customer some sense of
risk there will always be risk
councilors at committee represent a risk
to that but between us we can probably
say this is more risky that is that is
less risky if you do not provide
information on item A or B there will be
more risk
but the metric for it I think is
well lies then nice and statistics are
potentially a risk for us
thank you
um next on my list is counselor Lindsay
please and then councilor Carter
thanks chair
um
I just think there's a couple of looking
at the comments from officers
um there was a couple of comments about
the amount of time it took them to do
preamps
um
and I just wondered if
what the answer if there is a solution
to that
the comments I'm particularly looking at
there's one
um
yeah
0.4.6.5 on page 28
um the Third
item there in terms of resources there
is frustration that more officer time is
spent on straightforward proposals than
is needed whereas proposals that need
the time and energy putting into them
are not given the attention they need
and then somewhere else uh
we've got the comment that
um
I'm just trying to find where it is
yeah um 4.6.11
on page 32
um the one two three four five the six
point there an increase in fees to
account for the significant time spent
on drafting advice
this is officers are suggesting an
improvement by increasing the fees
some office officers have stated they
spend more time on a difficult pre-app
than other formal submissions and the
work they put in is not covered by the
fee requested
um
is that a
what would be a way of address is there
a way of addressing that
yeah yeah
go for it thank you
um
I think the the time spent on different
applications we had to allow for a
balance when we set up the charges
between we're not allowed to make a
profit it's got to be cost recovery and
how do you do that if we build following
the pre-app we could be more accurate
and we could allow for that time to
spend the time but equally we've then
got to spend the time in cost recovery
afterwards bit on with billing and
chasing so there was a judgment at the
time that this came in about how to do
that so there is always going to be a
degree of accuracy in what we're
charging versus the time I think we do
allow for a reasonable amount of time
we've been looking at that fairly
recently is how long does it take
compared to the costs so I would like to
hope it's relatively accurate there'll
always be at that degree
um and I think they are generally
you know there is a flexibility on off
the time I'm not there timing them
saying have you spent an hour on this
one then you're done they should be
looking to do what they need to do on
each one with that aim I think you know
as Phil will say about quality that
we're looking to provide that right
advice first time and that there will be
a balance on a simpler
application perhaps the timings spend
versus a more complex one that they
should yes they should be spending it
but that's part of the balance of the
process
thank you
yes please do
um so is there a I mean is there an
issue that I didn't quite understand the
the
um
the comment
from one of the officers
um
there's more of the time is spent on
straightforward proposals than is needed
what what's causing that is that
caused by
um just the the applicant not really um
um
knowing of knowing the ropes and and and
not not you know giving enough
information or
what's causing this frustration
the officers are actually spending
needing to spend more time they feel on
a straightforward something that should
be just almost yes or no I presume but
what's what's causing that
um I think there's a degree whereby they
do have to fill in the written version
and we try and provide as much
information as possible so there'll
always be a degree where you have got to
spend a certain amount of time filling
that in regardless of whether it's
something very small or something very
big and there's probably not a lot of
difference in time to run through the
policies fill them in run through the
plans fill them into that the system
runs appropriately
um so that possibly is part of that
frustration but probably difficult for
us to change that you will probably all
would want the policies there listed and
available for people so the officer has
got to input that
um and that can can add to the time in
the process equally there is that level
of information provided and as you say
people's experience with the planning
system so if somebody's given us all of
the plans for some extensions that we
could spend quite a amount of time on
because you've got plans you've got
details and
you know you you want to explain that to
give people the most possible help
compared to a big scheme either you
haven't got much information so you
might not have as much to say or you've
got a lot of information there's even
more to say so that it can be that
difference of the customer and what they
might need in order to get across the
line and what we can offer but also the
process and the background that's needed
to make that run
thank you councilor Carter
thank you
um start with I'd very much like the
officers about a comment about risk
learn down wrist and thing
um I wanted to ask about the
survey and how it's currently done and
how it would be
is it currently offered as a
case-by-case is it regards cases or is
it like given to developers over
applications they use over a case of a
year
is it recorded how many
blank responses we get if they don't
respond
or if they have responded
whether or not to the application was a
well positive negative whether or not to
be
whether or not to be got to be initial
feedback in favor of the development
um or whether initial advice was
initially in favor then declined or
whether or not or is it straight Flats
noted from a start
because is it a case of where the
application is made and expected to be
green lighted
and is being declined a surprise
so how are we numbering how are we
registering the
feedback we get regards to the
applications we if I get how can we can
tell if there's a large number of
negatives
because it didn't go in a way of the the
applicant wanted
or how many positives we get if it went
really well there is a in between period
we're not going to pop a responding
it's human nature to be rather hurt and
feedback negatively
rather and get more positives
and I did wonders well is the issues
that we've heard is it all from offices
where we come from offices where it's
been positive to start and then
when it's turned down by or goes against
is a solely
um irked by the officer officers or some
of it from when it goes to committee
and to be counselors because
degrees of risk
when officers have to go by planning
rules and planning things whereas the
counselors are there to look for the
actual area of application applications
going to isn't it to be expected if it
does it does go doesn't go to Prime or
maybe it's not been
the offices aren't going to be aware of
what's be Council that would be an area
is going to be looking for so how is
that being surveyed and is that some of
the degree of a
um negativity
I don't know how it if they made sense
in my head before I would open my mouth
so I hope I hope some of that made sense
I think were you were you asking if
there's some correlation between the
negative comments from the
um the pre-app people and uh and a
refusal whether whether it be a a
refusal by an officer as many of these
many cases are determined by an officer
or whether your biggest concern is
around an officer recommending approval
and a committee
resolving to turn down the application
is there any correlation between the
comments that the um those who are
answered the survey and the final
outcome is that the sort of thing you
were asking that's one of them
right can anybody tackle that John
um yeah so so the survey doesn't ask
about the outcome of the pre-app that
they've received so when we send out the
survey out it does not say um
positive neutral or negative response
the survey is anonymous as well so it
doesn't we can't identify which case
relates to which comment that could be
something that we could change with the
ongoing survey as well as asking the
question about specific case references
then we could tie it to the outcome we
could then tie it to the officer that
delivered the pre-app versus the formal
case we could we could add those
Parts into the new ongoing survey in
terms of a correlation we did do some
work in late 2019 2020 where we looked
at the outcome of the pre-app versus the
formal submission that followed and
whether there was a correlation between
the two and at that time there was a 95
correlation between what we said at
pre-app versus what the final outcome of
the formal decision was
we also looked at um negative comments
and negative outcomes in the pre-app
versus a positive Grant of decision so
that the person that had had the
pre-operative tech on board what we had
said and ultimately got a grant of
decision at the end of an approval so
that has been done previously that it's
a few years old again we could look at
that in our audit to see if there's a
correlation between what we are saying
versus the formal outcome and again we
could we could add the specifics into
the ongoing survey to find out
which case we are referring to which
officer dealt with that case and also by
doing that you would increase your
sample size because you're asking more
people to fill in a survey and uh
hopefully you'd increase your response
rate so you'd have more people filling
in the survey
with a larger sample size and
by having an ongoing survey it would
reduce the privacy and recency effect
where you only remember stuff at the
beginning or the end but we're capturing
everything through the whole journey
across the year
I hope that's yeah that's that's helpful
thank you
um
councilor Barrett you've got another
question I believe
thank you um councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman um
very interested in the
responses on questions 15 and 17. and I
would just um
like to ask do we gauge our responses
with other
District councils and would you consider
it helpful to do so
and does it give any benefit to to our
res you know to our
agents and applicants thank you
sorry chairman question 15 and 17 you
can just help me where we're looking at
for that
protein and the responses back from
from I take it the applicants
and the
and agents
.
and and now I'm just apologies Council
as you can repeat the question now I
know what the the reference is
I've looked through that and and I found
it a very interesting uh uh reply or
response but what the main question is
do you feel it worth uh or do you do any
um gauge uh
gauge our position with other District
councils basically and do you would you
think that would be helpful to know
where we're going with other councils
thank you
chairman I mean I think it's a mixed bag
trying to compare yourself to other
authorities because very much it depends
on the circumstances of the authority
the resources it has and its approach to
these things so
it's always useful to look at what other
authorities do for instance we've looked
at some of the work that haringey have
done around their charging circumstance
because that's available online I can't
personally recall seeing anybody else
whose surveys prep customers in quite
the same way that we do so I'm fairly
sure our Suffolk contemporaries don't do
this level of analysis of what their
customers want although I could stand to
be corrected I just haven't come across
it at this point
um and I think because it's very much
about improving our service within the
districts
comparison you know is very very it it's
it's very specific to what the
Authority's circumstance and resources
are to provide the service involved if
you wanted to get prep advice in London
for instance you will pay for it quite
considerably and obviously there's a
London waiting to salaries and other
things
but nonetheless
um
whether people are satisfied with what
they get I've got no information I can
give you this morning
thank you so we're fairly high on the
list basically
thank you thank you councilor acpa young
and then I've got a question around
validation and then I'd like us to move
on to debate
cancer appeal
thank you Mr chairman um
Mr Isabel talks about lies damn lies and
statistics and as a mathematician I'd
probably prefer the statistics element
of of things uh and if I look at
4.3.2 versus 4.3.3
then on average where it would appear
that customers are saying that the
advice on Heritage is much better value
than the advice on everything else I
mean if you look at the numbers an
average of 60 for Heritage and an
average of 43 for everything else or
other things so why is that why is the
advice so much better for Heritage
compared to the general advice
that's a very interesting question
Council Avenue and I've certainly met
agents who would say that's completely
untrue
um and their personal experiences that
actually that isn't what they react to
as how preact works for them
um
typically Heritage is very much
site-specific uh you you need to be
looking at prodding the building poking
it seeing the features of it to get to
that advice and possibly this gets back
to the point that the witnesses have
talked about in relation to face-to-face
meetings
um and but they obviously a Charged
feature it takes time to send officers
out on site to do these things and if we
have the situation uh where case officer
a deals with a case and sees the site on
the ground and then case officer B picks
it up because case officer a has a full
workload we have a degree of problem
there in the sense that the knowledge of
case office array isn't naturally
imported into case officer b i I don't
have any Instinct why that is but I
suspect it's possibly because the
individuals are on the site for most of
the advice being given
um and
um
are probably able to uh you know have a
face-to-face discussion about the merits
the issues and so on and In fairness you
might wish to ask Mr Brandt Mr Tanner
and Mr Platt what they think of of that
comparison and see what they say
on that
um like you I spotted the
sort of it seemed to be way out of whack
with all the others but
I think there's a function of sample
size here if there's only a that to me
that fluctuation you know 73 in 2018
down to 33 in 2019 up to 65 in 2020. but
you know you only need two people
there's probably fewer people coming on
Heritage than there is on the other
aspects because fewer people actually
need
free at Sugar Heritage so uh you only
need a couple of people
um to change you know to put to give a
negative
uh response and it goes down 10 so I
think that's probably the biggest factor
in this thank you
so
would an officer like to respond to a or
or
um yeah Mr thank you no problem um
I suppose it's broadly linked to the
question um
I think it's very difficult as an agent
and this will have some level of
sympathy for is
um the survey in itself I I think we
recognize and the feedback we have with
our clients
their um view of pre-app and actually
planning process as a hold is often
interlinked with the decision
so if you get what you want I you get an
approval or positive pre-app very much
clients will often be very I suppose
have you know be positive about that
process
so I think it's very it is very
difficult and how you how you achieve
that I'm just nothing to um to answer
but but separating out almost the
quality of service versus the outcome
I.E what the advice is is very difficult
I think as agents we have to try and be
fair and balanced enough to
assess the advice you know our opinion
May differ to the advice we have
and think about whether it represents I
suppose
um value for money and it's you know
quality and it and it means certain you
know requirements or things that we
expect
so you know my view would be as if I was
to ask some of my clients to complete
the survey
um you know I think they're
ultimately that whether the response or
pre-op response they had was positive
would I in my view highly or it affects
how they would respond to the survey so
I think that's very difficult to try to
separate the two out and have people
almost being partial in in completing
that survey uh survey so I do have you
know sympathy with that
um
I think they're moving to the to the
Heritage side of things um
personally I I suppose I don't feel as
though the Heritage advice that I've had
in the past is exemplary or you know
I think it has the same or I would voice
the same concerns that I have today
around you know quality advice being
range wide-ranging sometimes it's good
sometimes it's bad
um I think it's that I would offer the
same that actually that advice can very
often be delivered in a timely manner so
that's a positive
um whether it's to do with and I know
that I
you know somebody who was a property
owner a friend of mine sought some
pre-app advice around a satellite dish
on his property
um from Heritage so I think it's this
idea that maybe Heritage is quite you
know the uptake of pre-app at a sort of
um householder level from here from for
Heritage Services you know in my
experience anecdotally is quite high and
so if you're asking quite simple
questions
um and you're bound or more likely to
get a positive response
um you know your overall feeding towards
the process may be more maybe more
positive
um I think they're sort of things I
would say maybe anecdotally that I would
offer as reasons why the Heritage advice
may be or the the survey on Heritage
advice appears to suggest that it's
providing a better service than planning
I think from my point of view
um
I could get into or suggest that it
provides a poor service to planning but
you know uh yeah that's my my own
experience anyway
thank you um hopefully this is going to
be the last question sorry did you want
to respond yeah could I just add a
little bit to that because
um I think in the in the pre-app and the
planning process some of our biggest
frustrations have come from input from
the Heritage team actually
um so I when I look at the um the
surveys the figures that doesn't reflect
our general experience and
it's probably somewhat slightly unfair
because I think out of all the parts of
the planning process Heritage is
probably the most subjective I mean if
our three Heritage offers the same
questions you might get three slightly
different answers because it is a very
subjective part of the planning process
and I think again I've had a bit like a
broken record but it we've had a couple
of difficult applications where we've
had a meeting with one Heritage officer
formed a set of recommendations in terms
of planning drawings submitted it being
picked up by another Heritage officer
who just takes a completely different
View and it's sort of time and money and
frustration and the client just doesn't
understand where this difference comes
from so I think for us there are there
is improvements that could be looked at
much of what they are but it's very easy
to complain that with that government
solution I know but um I think there's
still some work to be done with the
quality of the Heritage um application
advice because it is so important I
would say probably agree that every list
of building that we deal with we would
with any sort of reasonable size
extension we would always seek
pre-application advice as part of that
process because it is so important when
you're dealing with Heritage assets and
I think there's probably still some work
to be done in in improving that um
particular part of the service
yeah yeah if I can continue throughout I
think I think a
positive aspect of the Heritage advice
is is
because the nature of it it needs to be
on site because you need to see the
building you need to investigate the
building and we encourage the applicants
and our clients to be at that meeting at
the same time so they can engage or
at least see us engage
um with the Heritage officer but I agree
that the consistency is important
um but this kind of leads back to a
couple of other points that were
mentioned earlier on and
um where we were saying the pre-app
advice maybe is suffering when we're
dealing with less senior officers
and also Phil mentioned earlier on that
you you acknowledge that you are you
know training your staff internally you
you haven't got a large influx of senior
planners and Heritage officers coming in
and you're having to internally train
them and this is where we as a practice
and and and probably other practices
well don't quite understand how you can
do that training when
the majority of your offices majority of
the time are working remotely you know
we have a flexible system I've got an
office of 23 guys we've got a flexible
system within the office so we do some
hybrid working but all our junior staff
are in five days a week because that's
how they learn that's how they absorb
um and if you've got a gene you know a
junior or less senior officer sitting at
home and working and without that backup
and that knowledge you know from all
their senior counterparts how can they
learn how can they provide quality
advice
how can they do that without that
support
um and that's where I think this lack
going back this lack of communication
because there isn't the confidence there
there isn't the confidence there to
provide that information to pick up the
phone to talk to agents which is is what
we're talking about here and and for us
communication is one of our core values
in our practice and something that I
think our clients recognize is is so
important
yeah thank you very much
um can I just ask a question around
validation of the pre-app so as I
understand it the application for
pre-app is made online and then
presumably is there a can I call them a
validation officer who's checking that
uh so the validation is is not carried
out by the the case officer for the
pre-app it's carried out by somebody
who's experienced in looking at pre-app
applications because there is a
suggestion uh well more than a
suggestion there are points in the paper
about that
that that
there's not always all the information
that the validation officer thinks
should be there
um and then there's a question that's
raised in there should the validation
officer contact internal consultees
um and there's also and perhaps I can
direct this at our Witnesses
um there isn't currently a list or a
checklist or should there be would you
benefit if there was a checklist and
could you have a checklist when you've
got such a variety of different
um a variety of different sizes of types
of application
if I pick that up yeah I think
I think like James said earlier on It's
Tricky for us to advise a client to
spend
you know money on a whole ream of
reports surveys designs at the early
stage until they have an understanding
of of whether this is going to be a
successful applicational proposal but I
think at the stage when we engage with
pre-app then to have some feedback at
that at that stage to say well look I
said earlier on if you provide this
report if we cover this you know this
issue out we can provide a more robust
response and that may be post
the written response we receive and it
may be that we say well we you know
maybe you can offer more of an open
service like some local other local
authorities do where you say right
here's the written response but if you
come back to me on this point at this
point we will keep it open and we will
give you that further response before
you go to the formal application
yeah I I bid I would be reluctant to see
a hardened validation list for
pre-application submissions I mean
obviously you need a site plan and you
need some basic information but I think
if there was anything that was vital um
to giving a robust response I'd like to
feel again it comes down to
communication and the after saying I can
provide you a response based on what
you've given but to really tackle this
difficult issue of x if you were to
provide more information we could give
you a more robust response
um but I I would be reluctant to sort of
fight with the validation team about
getting things over the line to start
the pre-application response because
they're so wide and so varied and
offered to it's and often it's
established this principle whilst
limiting the applicants risk exposure to
financial expenditure
uh yeah I think it's probably not a
similar
um foot really but I I think there's
there's a point here about ownership as
agents
um ultimately if you're providing a
certain level of information you have to
reflect on
response you're going to get as a result
of that and I think we're always trying
to to balance or tread
you know the tie rod between
um committing a client to significant
kind of upfront cost
um and that they're often the pre-op
process in my view
can be used or comes into its own when
you're trying to establish the principle
and always de-risk something for a
client so
um you want to provide a level of
information that will allow the officer
to engage with the key issues provide
you with some advice and Tackle those
what you see is key issues but equally
going to the length of a full design
package obviously comes at a cost
um so I think my personal feeling with
it is at the moment the the validation
criteria what you have to submit and I
think successfully
um
Treads that line really and is on the
right side where we can we can go
through a pre-app process justify a cost
to a client you know the level of
information that's required
um and we're not required to enter into
a kind of significant
um cost should we say
um
and I think to move it any further then
makes it I think inevitably brings about
a risk that it becomes
um difficult to justify for for a client
so I personally I don't think there's
any failing in the service at the moment
on its on its validation requirements I
think it does give flexibility and
allows things to be open and I think
agents really we should reflect on the
fact you know if we're wanting design
comments and quite frankly we've
provided an initiative layout and
haven't given any elevations well that's
some on us and and the advice we give to
our clients rather than the officer
thank you would one of the officers like
to say a few words on this topic thank
you
yeah it's just um
we we don't just have agents submitting
pre-application advice so we're
delivering we're trying to deliver the
service to quite a wide range of people
so it might just be the initial thought
that somebody wants to put an extension
on their property or it might be a much
more detailed scheme where agents and
Technical Specialists are involved as
well
so it's it's providing that sort of
balance between all customers I suppose
quite a lot of the fees that are paid
are paid are delegated by agents to
applicants to pay so sometimes there's a
little bit of a delay when we're when
we're registering applications
so when we talk about applications being
invalid at pre-application stage it's
sometimes because the fee hasn't been
paid and that's literally all that's
wrong with it
we are looking at having a site plan
because all our applications are plotted
spatially so we do need a minimum of a
site plan showing the exact site and
people's interpretation about what
they're going to put on that site
we do have quite a few inquiries which
basically say well what can I do then
and actually that isn't that isn't
something we can really investigate
that's probably the time when they need
to actually employ an agent to go
through that element and then come to us
after they've decided what they want
what they want to do
and I think
we could be better on the communication
I think we're looking at we're
understanding the process a lot more now
it's not have the pre-app
here's the answer go away come back
submit your application what we now need
to do is we need to join that process up
we we need to have the pre-application
come back if you make any changes maybe
do a validation check before you
formally submit
and then follow the process so it's it
is more linked for the time period we're
saying that that
um pre-application of advice is valid
for a period of six months but quite
often it might be day one we give the
pre-application advice six months or
longer than that before we actually get
the full notification but what we what
we really need to be doing is speaking
to agents and applicants before they
formally submit just to ensure there's
not been any changes to policies or
technical constraints it's an ongoing
situation now with ecology land
contamination flood risk things are
changing all the time so it's it's
getting that right before they submit
the formal application
because I think we could be much more
customer focused in that element
thank you very much so members we need
to have a look at the recommendations
that are before us we're not tied by
those
those recommendations
we can think outside the box we can come
up with something completely different
so if we do look at firstly out look
look at Pages 23 and 24
um one a couple of other things which
members might want to think about is
whether whether or not we
would suggest to officers that they
think about kpis
there are elements around training there
which have been mentioned
um
and I think the um the witnesses said
that perhaps they need to be
different arrangements or firmer
arrangements with um particularly on
floods advice
uh
and also there was the the point made
that it would be best perhaps if a
senior planner signed off the pre-app
advice
and we've also had the the the the the
thing about
um it's no good somebody sitting in a
silo hoping that they're gonna
get trained
at home looking at a laptop there needs
to be there needs to be a lot more
working together than
and that would suggest
so anybody got any any
a debate or any suggestions for
recommendations to cancel the Barrett
yeah
the oval oops it's on yeah on the
overall percentage sorry
um
would it be unreasonable to ask for a
target a target of 60 satisfaction
to be put in place as as something
because if we're saying we can't just
leave it and let it float I think it
should be that we say look this is a
reasonable Target and task
task that to be
um
to be put in place which is not
unreasonable I'm not saying let's go to
75 but go to 60 60 as a target of
satisfaction overall in the next 24
month period
because that gives plenty of time to be
able to
implement policies that might need
changing Implement any uh other issues
and I think that would be something for
the planning department to actually have
a time for us to just sit here and argue
I think we need to say yes we we accept
that these are difficulties it's a
difficult area but if we can get a
target of 60 up from 45 that's a good
increase and it shows that there's a
path of Direction
which I think would be acceptable to
hopefully my fellow counselors here and
um and to and to the public because I
think this is what we we are here to
represent the Public's point of view so
that's one point uh the other thing that
I also think we should um Implement
which worries me greatly and um
I think Phillips point is well
excised because I had the chance when we
were still in lockdown I went into the
planning department which was empty
apart from one planning senior planning
officer with a team
and he indicated to me that he wanted to
be there because he felt that the
younger members of the team did needed
his experience and worked with him
so
I think we should be also putting a
target of making sure I'm not sure where
how he actually word this but I think we
should have a target of working in the
building
because that clearly was picked up by
the witnesses and I think
um
uh to have that continuity which is
clearly what we're lacking here would be
something we should aim for now the
problem I see is that we are currently
in a position where we're reducing our
floor space by 50 percent
which would indicate that we are looking
to have less offices in anyway which
I've never agreed with because I didn't
actually agree with that so there would
be there but I think planning is
different from other areas because I say
planning
clearly if we are a training ground we
can't train at distance
do my colleagues think that's fair
um yeah I mean not necessarily this
building but they need to be working
together I mean it could be out on site
I mean there's a lot of value it doesn't
I mean it doesn't have to whether they
worked in groups whether they were you
know because we have green teams we have
blue teams we have other teams are they
are all the younger people being able to
get the continuity that they require
and and then the other point is
um on the historical stuff
I really do have issues and I sit on
planning and other people sit on
planning and the times we have problems
with
less than substantial harm
ing forward what does that mean
because I'm sure we all say well lessons
well that's obviously no harm
but according to different
interpretations within our own planners
interpretation we get a refusal or we
get an acceptance because it's then the
public benefit and we have to make that
decision not always
so it's that's that's another Point
um
I think uh was picked up by the
witnesses about that area in in the
historical thing I don't know whether we
can actually put that in
our recommendations that these areas
just need looking at I'm not suggesting
we change anything dramatically but
their areas of concern that we should be
making note of
Hinton
thank you Mr chairman
it's not very often I agree with
counselor Barrett but I think I agreed
near nearly everything he had had to say
that one of the things that that struck
me about the information before us was
looking at the key information 4.2
we're talking about this survey received
44 responses in a total 5.7 percent
this is compared to 61 responses being
received in the 2001 survey 8.3 percent
so the respondents is very low and that
effect is going to then skew the answers
that you interpret from it because one
person additional person responding and
coming up with a negative comment is
going to drop your percentages quite
considerably so I think one of the first
things we should be doing is trying to
get a greater level of people responding
to
our request for comments on service and
I think that's perhaps where the open
rather than annual
survey will probably help considerably
because it'll be easier for people to
put a comment at the bottom of their
reform than it will be for them to look
at something that comes through later on
in the year but I think that's one of
the things that we've got to try and
increase I agree with councilor Barrett
when it comes to the planning
officers being
together and in a location
to improve on the training aspect and
that could effectively
increase the
quality of the responses that are going
out to pre-application advices so where
we're talking about less than
substantial harm they will all agree on
what it is rather than one officer
putting in on a pre-application that is
less than substantial and another
officer has to determine the application
because presumably somebody else will
determine the application if it's an
officer delegated decision otherwise
you've got predetermination coming into
it straight away
um
there's going to be a difference in an
opinions about potential for differences
and opinions if they're all together
it's much more reliable for them to get
a
comment on it
yeah I yeah I think we we all understand
that but what we can't do is tell tell
the officers how they have to manage
their staff
um so we that's that's something which
we need to Bear remind
um so yeah
do you want to come in now Mr as well uh
if I may turn yes I'm very very
conscious that the message from the
chief executive has very much been that
you can work from wherever you are so we
have to ride
the horse of training people up and I'm
not entirely convinced that
um physical presence necessarily
actually gets learning going I think
there are sometimes you know as I did
back in the day you learn from the
experience in the room of hearing other
people have conversations you gain
experience by talking to other officers
including those who Mentor your Mentor
you and and your peers
um and and we're also going to a changed
floor plate in terms of accommodation so
we've got a number of problems here
which
in terms of managing the service we just
have to be thoughtful how we go through
I I think the point about some officers
might prefer to be in in together
actually
um consolidating the space can actually
be very distracting for officers and
they don't get work done so there are
productivity questions that happen where
you have
activity around you there are learning
points that happen when you have other
people's experience that you can see and
gain from
I I recognize what's being described by
councilor councilor Hinton
um I think
the the how we do this to make sure we
consistent with what the chief executive
saying about
um you know having to attend anywhere
which has been a very clear message
through his briefings to officers I
think we do need to be a little
thoughtful how we we go through that but
I understand the training point and the
important thing is that people learn
from experience by
being present with others in some
location and I understand that I'm not
quite sure how to actually deliver that
right I've got I've got hands up
counselor Lindsay was next no sorry
counselor Grandeur was next they
encounter Lindsay and then councilor
Mueller have I got any other hands
councilor appeal
so councilor Grandin please
thank you Mr chairman
um well I suppose
I was planning to talk on but I suppose
on the
um working from home versus working from
um the building point of view most
offices now have a core days
um routine where
um staff are expected to be in on
certain core days and then most people
are in you know
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday or whatever
so that's how
most offices certainly in London seem to
work now and my children's offices work
so that would be quite an easy solution
to
form a compromise there
um and on the
um thoughts that councilor Hinton
mentioned about getting in improved
feedback
on from applicants and their agents I
wonder whether
um we all get used to when we make a
purchase or deal with an organization up
Pops full saying how did we do
from you know on an email
um I wonder if something like that at
the completion of
either after pre-app or
after the end of the application I'd
have thought in this situation after
pre-app whether it became an automatic
thing
the planning team to send out uh how did
we do type thing how can we improve or
whatever
our service and that if that became the
norm obviously not everyone's going to
fill it in even then
but it will be fresh in people in in the
um applicants mind
as to how
they felt about the service so you would
and and you'd have more chance of
getting getting that feedback rather
than everyone getting
um
these forms at a particular time I mean
actually five percent isn't if in
advertising terms
um or marketing terms five percent isn't
a bad feedback but this is a very
specialist
um
request for feedback that you would have
thought the
um
um applicants would have
an interest in providing the answers so
it must be the way that we're doing it
that
um they're not we're not getting more
um people
um taking part in the
um survey so but I think perhaps if you
sent it immediately after the
um pre-app then you you might get
improved feedback so I hope that helps
thank you yeah thank you before we move
on I wonder if to cover the points
raised by counselor Barrett counselor
Henson we should
um
can I offer something along the lines of
that we request the director of planning
a building control and chief planning
officer to consider arrangements to
provide training and mentoring
opportunities for all
planning staff with a with a view to
improving the level of pre-app service
yeah thank you
so I've now got four speakers I've got
councilor Lindsay next
thanks chair
um yes that's a good oh dear you
you
[Music]
um
also
I picked up from our Witnesses the
the need for the continuity winner
the preamp
the case officer who goes on to
determine the actual application and um
you know there's a need for the
when the change when a change happens if
the pre-app officer isn't going to be
the
the case officer going forwards then I
need to talk to whoever is the new case
officer
now I don't know quite how we put in a
recommendation but for but but you know
I think
be along the lines of the pre-app
officer
[Music]
um
communicates with
there is a new case officer
um
talks to that new case officer
I I would suggest that's probably
tinkering with the way that they they
that they operate in there in in the
department and that the the sort of
overall
recommendation I've suggested could
easily cover that to ensure that there
is
discussion between
the various members of staff
okay and and the the other
um
thing I just wanted
I think I I'm not quite clear the
wording of 3.4 and 3.5 recommendations
it's quite of uh I've read them three or
four times over um
it's 3.5
we're saying that
the corporate director planning and
build control and the chief planning
officer review the result review the
surveys
and the audit
that's been done is that what it's
saying or is it saying that they do an
audit themselves
by any
saying that I think what 3.5 is saying
that the results are 3.2 3.3 and 3.4
will be looked at by the director by the
chief planning officer and the two
cabinet members
okay
that makes sense then and I just suppose
I just wanted to
underline the importance then of 3.4
um because it does strike me to that and
this is explained in items 4.7 and 4.8
on page 32 that
that
the importance of having to this this
structured audit where you
you pick out sample cases randomly and
and check them for quality and check
them for consistency as well
[Music]
so
um
I think that's what 3.4 is saying
um that there are two kinds of
that you're going to do two kinds of
audit one one checking on the um
just on the pre-application Vice
per se and the other one checking that
the pre-application advice is consistent
um with what happens with the formal
application
is that is that right I think I think
it's to check the correlation between
the two and if they're if there is if
there is a cons if there's a consistent
difference between the advice
that a particular officer is giving
giving and the ultimate outcome then
that's something which can be a a trade
a training a sort of a learning issue uh
Mr Isabel
indeed german yes I mean I think to make
this effective you would look at
applications which have been decided and
then which have pre-app associated with
them and then go into the detail of
auditing that to establish whether the
advice given was timely was consistent
with with the proper position on on
things taking the experience of those
doing the audit delivered customer
service and um and what you generally
call Quality and giving advice around
things like risk assessment and and
other so as I mentioned to councilman
young the intention is to do that
monthly it's not stated in the
recommendation but if if one wish to
state that one could easily do that I
think if you do it more frequently it
will become burdensome
um and and similarly I think uh if you
if you um you could do it monthly you
could do it quarterly both of those are
perfectly effective time models to do
these things but clearly there is some
lag that's inevitable that a planning
application will follow along from a
prayer
uh having listened to that in 3.4
change the word regular to quarterly I
think if to do it monthly
um you might you might you might have a
some pre-app one month and about four
months later you've got the officer
report and then a month after that
you've got the decision I think to do it
every month is probably a bit too much
but if they wanted to do it every month
then
by us suggesting quarterly wouldn't
preclude that
um I've got counselor Muller next on the
list
thank you chair
um I totally agree with um councilor
Barrett who regarding the kpis on the
survey I think that's that's quite a
normal practice I think you know this
type of thing I also support the
recommendation you read out about the
training Etc but it was also pointed out
earlier that in fact the junior planning
officers obviously they do liaise with a
more senior officer so as I understand
it then they wouldn't send out the
pre-application device to the applicant
or the agent until that had been looked
at by their senior officer
so that's how I understood it could that
just be confirmed that is the case
please
yep so that goes through a process of
checking between offices so they'll have
a mentor who would they would discuss it
with and it also goes through the
signing process where a senior officer
does have to check and then they will
issue it essentially in the senior
officer's name goes on the system as
well yeah thank you so I would argue
that's also a really good part of the
the learning process the trading process
which obviously is very keen that that
sort of thing continues it obviously
does work well in the actual team so
that's a thank you
and then I'd like us really to move
towards these recommendations thank you
how's it working on
thank you Mr chairman
um so I I do agree about the issue of
how we approach the way in which our the
junior staff within the planning
department work I think you know Mr
Isabel mentions the direct director from
the CEO I think we have to bear in mind
that
um you know it's it's all well and good
for senior staff who've got lots of
experience to work remotely it's not the
same situation at all with junior staff
and one only has to look at the press to
see large corporations demanding that
all their trainee staff go back to the
office
um because that's much more effective
and efficient way of getting them
trained faster more efficiently
um so I I mean while I I understand that
Mr Isabel as a department manager
following the CEO's Direction the CEO's
direction is not a Carl Blanche you know
we have it has to be tailored to each
particular situation and for me you know
it's really important for junior staff
to get that feeling of belonging and
working with each other and learning off
each other and so on and so forth you
just can't replace that with remoteness
um it's just not possible and that's why
major corporations you look at the city
they're all asking their staff to come
back to the office because that's the
problem they're facing okay so I think
you know I want to make that point the
second point is I would like to see a
modification to
um
recommendation 3.5 because we see in the
key information 4.2 that the results of
annual surveys are reported the
client-side panel and I believe some of
the Witnesses are on this panel and what
is not
and you know in my experience you can
learn a lot from talking to your
customers so if we're if we're going to
be having this review I think might
start with the officer core themselves
but I think that should also include the
client-side panel who should be able to
provide some very useful feedback as to
things that could be done better you
know because it's in their interest to
have a better service
so I would like to see that that change
um and I think the other point I'd like
to make it is I I pick up on councilor
grandin's point which is that the the
proportion of respondes it seems
relatively low for this particular type
of service I mean on a generic service
those would be fantastic responses
camera but for a specific service like
that that does seem low and I think we
we ought to be uh the officers need to
to go back and look at the the sorts of
questions that they're asking their
customers um
which is something I find because you
know you it does become stale and so you
need to kind of
refresh it every so often
go on that last point we could alter
perhaps alter 3.2 obviously be requested
to alter the frequency and
um format of
yeah
out of the frequency and content of the
survey
yeah you happy with that
right I'm gonna hear now from counselor
Carter
oh sorry 3.5
process
um
Mr Ismail is there a problem with that
because I think you already report the
surveys to the client side panel so
would you be content to include in that
review the result of the immense surveys
and audits at least by the in
consultation with the cabinet members
for planning and and report to the
client-side panel of professional agents
would it be review
with
the client-side panel and report to the
cabinet members run the other way around
it seems the right way around to report
to cabinet members rather than to report
the client side panel that seems a
little count for a horse but
who can give you obviously valuable
feedback which you can then report to to
come and take on board yourselves yes
yes right
um while I'm writing can we hear from
councilor Carter then please
yes going back to a point from Council
Lindsay I would actually
highly recommends Us in including their
um improving Handover procedures or
formalizing recorded Handover procedures
they may already be in place but it can
always go as a recommendation for us
which may improve some of the feedback
we are getting some of the some of the
discussion within officers if there's a
standardized recorded Handover process
between officers
um I did but I also wonder
regards to kpis I would I know we want
to keep this rather
um
anomalous but to have it record somehow
have a
survey with a recorded of whether or not
to be advice it gave in is what they
want to know whether it's approval or
decline uh
there's always going to be basically
just to ensure that it's recorded
whether or not it's a case of human sour
grapes if I think what they want we're
likely to have more negative
and so if
yeah the regardless of how small a
feedback we get is going to be recorded
about whether or not it's the feedback
we are getting is
of a
a usable quality as it were
yeah thank you for that I'm not sure how
we can weave that into the
recommendations unless somebody can come
up with something but in the meantime
can I can I attempt to read my scribbles
and we have on page 23 we have
recommendation three one which we're not
minded to alter in any way
for 3.2 that officers be requested to
alter the frequency
um and
I think that's meant to be content of
um survey and customer of customer
experience of the pre-app service to
open rather than annual
that
um that officers be requested to
undertake an annual survey of
development management planning offices
of their experiences of customer service
that's unchanged 3.3 3.4
we changed that to be that offices
developer model for quarterly audit of
timeliness Etc
3.5
uh that the corporate director of
Planning and Building control and chief
planning officer resume the result of
the above mentioned surveys and there's
probably results of the above mentioned
surveys and audience with the
client-side panel and report at least by
annually to the cabinet members for
planning
is that what we had in mind
and then a 3.6
which
we request the director for plenum
building control and the chief planning
officer to consider arrangements to
provide
adequate training and mentoring
opportunities for all planning staff
with a view to providing an improved
level of pre-app service
are you
members are you all content with those
six recommendations
do you want to see them written
request
request the director for Planning and
Building control and the chief planning
officer
to consider arrangements to provide
adequate training and mentoring
opportunities for all planning staff
with a review to providing an improved
level of pre-app service
customer satisfaction just as a tail end
on that
um I think it would have to be would
that be or would that be a separate
separate
yeah have that as a 3.7 yeah
yeah 3.7 key
so that's it's the overall quality of
advice as in three four point three
point four on page 25.
sorry
4.3.4
yeah yeah sorry yes that that we'd like
to see by 2024 or 25 that that has gone
up to 60 percent
yeah I'm gonna write this first
Bell uh yes Jim you you said 20 24 25
I've just for a kpi to where I was
wondering when we want to have got to
this point just what's what's the
expectation date that we're looking to
from my point of view the next financial
year
23-24
I would I would I would suggest that
that's that's a very sharp
Improvement I think it needs to be
longer than that now would would the
survey be over a calendar year or a
municipal year and
um
in the
in the in the 12 months to
uh
first to the 31st of April 2025.
well that
whatever
yeah that's what we said
be realistic
what can be achieved
um
the way that councils operate
if they're um I mean if there are
changes that need to be made within the
department in order to do that they need
a time to make those changes if they hit
it beforehand that would be great
there's no problem
um
so that I've written down here
I'm not saying this is perfect yet that
the
um
corporate director for Planning and
Building control and the chief planning
officer aim for an overall quality of
advice level of satisfaction of 60 in
the 12 months to 30th of April 2025.
yeah of the results is 53 so you're
asking for an improvement of seven
percent over a two-year period doesn't
seem very much of a Target to me
and if you look also look at the detail
of the statistics on three occasions
they've been within five percent in fact
in one case it was almost 60 so I mean I
think you know in terms of stretching
targets 60 is not my stretch
over two years
Mr Isbell can I suggest two factors
there firstly we're changing to a
in response survey so we've served
annually we're now going to a real-time
survey so we don't know what we get out
of that so that may well completely
alter those
thanks
and secondly take back the point that Mr
Platt made people get a negative result
they may well feel inclined to be
negative about this so
quality and that sense of response
that may just be bad luck for somebody
in tough that they don't like the answer
they got and they will feel sore about
it and
I'm afraid the local Authority is a
regulator in this role we are not
providing something which is absent of
that understanding so
it's the same with most elements that
involve customer service you know as the
witness he said if they get a fantastic
that it concurs with what they expected
they go you guys have done really
brilliantly if you get a really poor
response they don't like they think
you've done a really poor job
that happens in all kinds of service
environments so I think you know I take
your point but I don't think it's
totally you know pertinent in terms of
looking at what the target should be can
we get back sorry sorry to interrupt can
we get back to these recommendations
um I've read them out in fences starts I
are you can are you content with them
does somebody want to change change them
does somebody want to propose these
recommendations
I'd like to propose them as you've
wrapped up
because before we do that I I think we
need to change the target from 60 to a
higher figure over the two years
to
um
4.34 considering the overall quality of
advice for Ratings that was 45.5 percent
well that's just one instance
let's let's not have a discussion about
that we've got to decide whether we're
going to go for 60 in two years time or
something else I there seems to be some
sort of General consensus that 60 by
30th of April 2025 is is about right
um and I I understand your point Council
actor young but
I I go back to our chief planning
officer's initial response to my very
first question was he said he'd like to
get to 50 percent
so I've given him a Target well we've
given him a target of 10 over what his
ambition was so I think that's I think
that's fair I think I think we shouldn't
all right right okay so do I have a
proposal then please councilor Barrett
and the second uh councilor Grandin
thank you do you want me to read it all
out again no
not enough are you are you content then
that we go to
we can we can work it out we can work it
out afterwards if we can go to
um go to the electronic vote then please
thank you chair members that voters now
in progress
councilor Osborne you want me to take
your vote verbally
okay
fine thank you chair that is 11 votes
for so that's unanimous thank you
thank you very much indeed everyone can
we have just a five or six minute break
thank you
um yeah we're we're now going to deal
with item 10 on the agenda which is
private sector housing enforcement and
civil penalties policy
and I'd like Jan Osborne Cabinet member
for housing for baber to introduce the
paper please
containing any and even housing
standards in the private rented sector
private renter sector contributes
towards meeting housing need in both
districts
most landlords provide good standard
accommodation for their tenants and
manage their property satisfactorily but
this is not so in all cases
the report proposes a new enforcement
policy for our private sector housing
work it outlines the current work of our
housing standards team which is
responsible for ensuring that housing
conditions are safe and healthy for
residents which is a statutory Council
Duty
at its heart the enforcement policy
seeks to provide Clarity for landlords
and agents on what is expected from them
and the responses they can expect from
the council
do service requests in most cases this
involves advice and encouragement to
meet minimum legal standards
the policy also outlines guidelines for
officers to ensure enforcement is taken
consistently fairly and using good and
fair practice
wherever possible we'd prefer to work
with landlords in order to resolve
problems to improve standards the report
proposes to charge for officer and
administration time to recover costs
where formal action must be taken when
it has to resort to using such powers
this policy is not intending to
prescribe the action that will be taken
in every situation it will guide
officers when investigating cases
serving notices or taking enforcement
action including legal proceedings
it is important that officers have the
option to make use of all powers
available to them the government has
given powers to local authorities to
take stronger action where it is
Justified in the private rented sector
these are known as civil penalties and
are an alternative to prosecution
they enable us to penalize the worst
landlords through direct Financial
sanctions or prosecution and will only
be used for serious offenses or where
compliance cannot be achieved
Council has developed its civil
penalties approach outlined in appendix
2 after collaboration with colleagues in
Suffolk and liaise with our legal
department this will ensure that
penalties are proportionate to the
offense and applied fairly
there is a system of receiving
representations against the imposition
of a fine and a legal appeal available
in these cases it is in line with the
government's intention to prevent
landlords from benefiting from unlawful
Behavior
the council intends to use these Powers
sparingly only where Justified and
generally where enforcement action has
failed to obtain compliance any
penalties received will be retained in
the team's budget thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much now I believe David
David Weber
has a short presentation for us is that
right thank you
good morning my name is David Weber I'm
one of the environmental health officers
that work in a small team of
really a couple of officers that really
work to
ensure that housing standards in
predominantly in the private rental
sector
are healthy and safe for tenants in
private rented accommodation so we deal
with some service requests from
customers about poor housing conditions
we also license some houses in multiple
occupation
and
um we do our our work is really
um more about regulating standards and
some of the other things that we do so
we do offer Financial incentives to um
grants to help people in need and we
also deal with some empty properties to
help uh bring them back into use for
um to maintain housing Supply and make
best use of the stock in in the um in
the private
with private uh sector properties so
these are the kind of things that we
really get involved with and this report
is about
um really bringing into place the new
civil penalty powers that are available
to all local authorities and our
are generally available to support an
enforcement approach where that is
needed
which tends to be really pretty much in
the in the in in the as a last resort
in cases that we deal with
so the
this the Civil penalties that we've got
they they are forming part of this
private housing enforcement policy we
felt it wise to because of the
complexity of the laws that we enforce
we felt it was um
wise to have a standalone policy that
sits under the council's corporate
policy council's corporate policy covers
all of um
paper mid suffolks work in terms of
being forced but be it planning
food safety all sorts of other areas so
housing is one component of that and the
powers are are pretty specific that we
use we felt it was it was best to have a
specific housing policy in this report
which outlines really what our powers
and our Duties are so we have some
statutory duties there's certain things
we must do with people complain to us we
must investigate the complaints and we
must be aware of kind of some of the
housing conditions in our in our
districts as well
so that the policy aims to be really
kind of open and transparent about when
we're going to use different types of
action when we're going to work with
landlords when we're going to work
informally and that is the heart of our
work really is talking to talking to
landlords trying to get some
improvements done and working with
landlords as well when they've got
inquiries and want some help on them
meeting legal standards
um we work quite closely with landlords
and we do do quite a lot of that already
and we this isn't going to change in any
way it just provides us with some with
with
um a form a form of words if you like on
when we will take action
um how and how we go about
um
exercising our statutory duties and um
powers and as I say most of that uh in
in the policy outlines when we will take
informal action and we take the
different types of formal action as well
these powers are large almost entirely
reserved for private rented type of
properties
part of the enforcement policy you'll
notice that there are some appendices
attached to this report and they cover
our approach to some more recent Powers
which are called civil penalty Powers
they are an alternative in in the really
the worst cases that we would be coming
across we have been doing some work with
both the police and the fire brigade
over the last year and a half on on
areas such as modern day slavery money
laundering and other criminal activities
and unfortunately some some housing in
their private rented sector does does
come into play as part of that joint
working that we do with the enforcement
authorities
we do have impact days which we call
them with the fire brigade we check
properties on a risk basis we try and
identify the worst properties in certain
areas or where we feel that there may be
problems and we do joint visits fire
brigade
viral thoracy and we also have
um some work that we've done with the um
with the police related to criminal
activity and housing and I'll just show
you one of one of those kind of cases
that we've been involved with in a
minute with some photographs
so in terms of our civil penalties these
are all an alternative to prosecution
proceedings
if we ever took a prosecution we'd
always have to prove have evidence to
prove the case beyond all Reasonable
Doubt and that is exactly the same for
using a civil penalty so civil penalty
is an alternative to a prosecution it
allows the council to Levy a fine of up
to 30 000 pounds in the worst cases
that's a ceiling figure
what we've developed and I think
appendix 3 is the Civil penalties policy
we've done some work with other Suffolk
councils to Benchmark that and we've
also looked at sentencing guidelines
from from the police to come up with
figures which we feel are are are fair
we feel that they're accurate and we
feel that they provide a good
a a good range of
um penalty levels in the fines should we
ever need to Levy a civil penalty
civil the Civil penalties are subject to
as I said the same we'd have to say we'd
have to prove the same level of evidence
that we do for a prosecution and there
is um we'd have to follow government
guidance
on how we go about doing that so we
would um
we'd have to go follow
guidance on looking at the nature of the
offense how serious the offense was how
the perpetrator
Behavior affected the offense and look
at any mitigation before we actually
came up with a figure using the matrices
independent 3 to determine a fine level
we've been encouraged by government to
adopt these powers and we have included
them in the new enforcement policy
um there are considerable advantages to
using civil penalties over over
prosecutions
um
they are really that we
um it's a quicker route it avoids
clogging up the court system which is
quite overloaded at the moment and also
avoid some types of uh perhaps less less
serious offenses going to prosecution
where where we would still need to take
action
um
so there are some benefits or there's
also a benefit in that we retain the
money in the council's budget from
income and we can then use that but we
can only use that to further the work
that we do in the private rented sector
so there is some benefit there to a
continuation of targeted work
um and we also avoid lengthy Court
proceedings
so a few examples I've just shown there
where where these new civil penalty
um new civil penalties may be helpful to
us
so I've outlined a few different cases
there
so um
we would always make a decision on
whether to prosecute or to issue a civil
penalty in conjunction with the count
with legal advice that we take and we'd
work closely with our legal department
in informing a in making a decision so
the first example there is where perhaps
we had a serious problem in the private
rented sector where someone was had been
rented out of property maybe above a
commercial premises or something like
that which required and maybe it was a
multiple occupied property which is
quite high risk for a fire and there
happened to be a fatality there we there
may there would be an offense under our
housing Acts because it would be so
serious we'd probably be looking at a
prosecution something like that should
it occur rather than issuing a civil
penalty
in the second case
this is more about perhaps whether we
had received a complaint from someone we
investigated there was some quite
serious problems with things perhaps
such as dampness or serious disrepair
broken heating system another quite
serious hazards that get rated as being
quite a problem and likely to affect
tenants health or their safety in that
particular case if we if we'd gone
through all the process of engaging with
the landlord we couldn't get compliance
we had to serve a formal notice we gave
adequate time to do the work and still
without good reason to work
will not be done and probably even after
that we offered further opportunities
for compliance and and they failed we
would then move to be issuing a civil
penalty and we determined that in in
accordance with our civil penalties
um
policy that we've got
the third example really um
houses in multiple occupation of a
certain size which is generally where
they're sharing and over over five
persons in Residence these have been
needed to be
licensed under the mandatory National
licensing scheme for um since about 2014
so what we would normally do we if we do
if we did come across this we wouldn't
just um issue issue civil penalties
straight away we would we would look to
towards giving
opportunities to license the property
and warning letters before we resorted
to civil penalty but those examples
there just give you perhaps in a flavor
of the sort of approaches and different
scenarios that we come across
um
we also feel that we should be charging
for well we do have to resort to four
more formal notices and we have to take
some sort of initial um some sort of
formal action that we should be charging
for the office of time involved in doing
that the reasoning being that the
majority of our landlords are are good
are compliant they offer good properties
for people and they provide a housing
need if people are if some landlords are
cutting corners and really don't want to
comply with the law
um it perhaps it could be seen as being
only fair that if the council then has
to use its own resources to intervene
and take formal action that we should
recover those costs of preparing legal
our legal formal documents to get lands
to do some work so we'd only do that
really when we're taking formal actions
such as
serving prohibition orders prohibiting
the use of a property or maybe work
conditions are so bad that we'd have to
ask a landlord to formally improve the
property
the charges will be based on officer
time taken and they are set out in
government guidance so they're very
clearly defined on what we can charge
for
this isn't it just an example of where
we did some work with the police
in a property that was linked to alleged
criminal Behavior the property we came
across with antisocial behavior and we
were asked to attend with the police it
was a result of action that we we took
we prevented the property initially from
being used by issuing what is known as a
privition order to due to some very
serious and dangerous uh conditions that
we found out the property when we
attended the property it was um it was
multiple occupied there were a number of
signs of evidence of that with um shoes
and multiple rooms shoes at the in the
entrance of multiple different persons
and various bedrooms being occupied some
of the conditions we came across were
quite dangerous and
problematic so we had three rooms at the
property
I'll just flash through these really
these were the kind of um these were
some of the bedding and the beds that
people were sleeping in in different
rooms
uh the kitchen was in a seriously
unhygienic and
quite unsafe conditions due to poor
electrical installations
there were
you know really unsuitable
um water connections there was flooding
of the property at the rear the drains
were all blocked there was dangerous
electrical supplies at the property the
um
washing facilities weren't particularly
good to say the least and we're quite on
a hygienic there's been vandalism in the
property due to people breaking into it
um which you can see here so there was a
risk of intruders entering the property
um some of the electrics were had
exposed conductors and were quite
dangerous and they said that's just one
example where there's a number of
offenses there and at the moment all we
could in the initial work that we did
was to prohibit the use of the property
but we could also use our civil penalty
Powers perhaps to Levy a strong uh Levy
a fine for offenses on that particular
landlord of that property
so um that's just a brief summary of the
sort of work that we do and why we'd um
like um some some comments perhaps and
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that we've got today on
um on our policy and I'm I'm with my
colleague um
thank you very much you do excellent
presentation I think we all know much
more about the topic now thank you
members are there any questions just
questions please Council scarf and
councilor Muller
um page 111 gives us the penalty Banks
and it gives us the starting points in
the penalty band range I'd just like to
sort of understand the range for example
in low culpability the first one
lists a starting point of 1500 pounds
and a range for the penalty band range
of between 750 and 2250 is the range
something that's set by government and
the starting point is something that
you're recommending to us
because obviously the starting point is
higher than the minimum that's the first
question
and also if we issue a civil penalty
notice to a landlord are we are we able
to use that in the same way as a press
release following a successful
conviction of a landlord
because
I feel that if we are able to advertise
digress from what would be expected
through a press release following a
court case that actually says quite a
lot
but would a civil penalty notice be able
to be used in the same way or as a civil
point you notice literally issued and
there can be no advertisement about it I
use a digitarian factor
I mean on that second point I'd I'd say
I don't know the answer to that and I
would have to take
um further advice on whether certainly
you can with prosecutions and I'm well
or whether they've been pressed releases
and I've done myself at certain places I
I would just need to check with civil
penalties whether they can be uh put
into the public domain personally I
can't see why not but because it's a lot
I think probably the point you're making
is because it's civil rather than a a
criminal offense then that may um
determine whether or not you could
publicize it and put it into the public
domain certainly I can add to that by
saying certainly there is a a national
register now of offenses an all-civil
penalty offenses can be put on the
public register that
so that is one way of making certainly
making people the rent properties more
aware of who bad landlords are in any
part of the country at the moment
um on the first point on the
on the starting points that you
mentioned so they've been really ranged
between
um a very low start point of 1500 up to
30 000 now
um I think before that page you can see
how we come across
um determining what those starting
points are so for each particular case
we would look at what the culpability is
and what the
um
what the harm is and there are some I
think there's some boxes in 5.4 above
and 5.3 above that so these are the
sorts of behaviors that you can see that
would likely to lead to us then looking
at a starting point for an offense so
you may have some quite minor offenses
at the bottom end of the scale and as
you um I still have as you said you
talked about the 1500 pounds so that
would be uh quite a low a starting point
for quite a low
um grade of offense but what we would
then do is have it if we considered the
starting point of 1500 pounds we before
we got to that stage we'd look at the
severity of the actual offense then we'd
point to the 1500
um
fine
as our starting point and we would
adjust that up and down depending on
factors such as the um the culpability
of the offender any mitigation received
the portfolio for land or we might it
might be more appropriate to issues go
go to a slightly higher area for a large
portfolio of folio land or two should do
better who should who should know
exactly what's going on in his business
rather than someone who at the low end
of the scale has only got one or two
properties so all these factors are
taken into account using the government
guidelines and adjusting that starting
point figure to come up with a final
figure following consultation with the
legal department
thank you um councilor Mullen is an
excellent counselor Carter uh thank you
chair
um
how many prosecutions I know there there
is a last resort but how many
prosecutions have you perhaps done in
the last 18 months
in these sort of cases please
the number of prosecutions is zero the
level of enforcement activity is not
very high and that's driven by two
factors one around the number of
complaints that we receive and as David
touched upon earlier we much prefer to
work with the landlord to advise
get them encourage them to bring the
property up to standard to avoid that
enforcement action so today in the last
18 months zero
thank you and my other question is on
the example that you've actually used
whereby you would prosecute and you said
we would take the appropriate action so
I know that's a hypothetical potential
hypothetical example but if you were
taking the action for a prosecution
would you undertake like the interview
for an interview under caution or would
the police do that for you
um if it's a if it's offenses under the
housing accent under this policy we
would be issuing the uh formal cautions
right um so we would conduct that
process under the police and kill
criminal Evidence Act
Ive training in doing that
thank you very much thank you
thank you um councilor Carter please
uh yes going back to the first example
where
we took action after as a fatality for
lack of fire alarms
is there any cause of action where we
can take prior to that if there's a lack
of fire alarms or carbon monoxide alarms
because
surely it's a bit extreme and it well I
would say that prevention is better than
it's not exactly a cure for death
it'll be my first question I've got a
few others after
so I think that that first example I
mean it was a hypothetical example but
we would always expect if we've got a
property that's multiple occupied then
we would look at making sure if we came
across that property inspected it we
would always expect there to be
a means of Escape in case of fire that
was adequate an adequate other five
precautions so what we'd be looking for
really is is
a safe meeting to escape for people an
adequate a lot
and fire doors and detectives and things
like that so if we came across the
property and there'd been a fire and a
fatality and the landlord hadn't put any
of those in
then we would be looking
um
severity of of that and the fact that
that property should be subject possibly
to mandatory licensing if there were
five or more people and they haven't
done so that but we consider those all
really quite serious offenses so they'd
be right at the top end of the scale of
seriousness of the severity of the
offense really so we would be looking at
prosecution but your point about if we
came across that generally I mean land
would generally know what they're they
should know what their um
that that business is if they are
running multiple occupy properties they
should be compliant and do do a risk
assessment of their property check what
they need in their property take advice
and make sure it's compliant if um on
the other Scout on the other scale of it
right on the other scale if we came to a
property and it didn't have it was
deficient maybe with fire doors then we
would perhaps serve an improvement
notice for the property to be improved
or we'd offer a land or some initial
guidance to help comply first versus
minor digression so that's what this
enforcement policy is about really it
talks about working with landlords and
informally and working with them but
then there is a scale of different types
of interventions that we can use which
at the top end is prosecution and at the
right the normal end which is how we
work with that and also engage with them
but somewhere in the middle there we've
got some other powers around you know
coming across properties for perhaps
non-compliant and landlords aren't
prepared to engage and they wouldn't be
prepared to do the work unless we served
a former notice on them so there's all
these different types of
approaches that we can take and because
houses are multiple occupation multiple
occupied properties are quite high risk
from a fire point of view they are
subject to an additional layer of
management regulations that also produce
produce some more requirements for them
because of the high fire risk but they
also mean that if they don't comply with
them the council can take action for
management regulation offenses so they
would be civil penalties so there's so
it's a bit complicated price but I'm
just outlying all the different types of
action that we have available to us and
how compliance should should occur
really
and on the
scale
um I am aware of there have been cases
not in our
region I've been cases of
landlords having multiple properties
um being linked to criminal activities
either setting the information on
vulnerable tenants into instance of
cooking
also the same landlord having a HMO
where it links to slavery I'm assuming
these cases would be a prosecution issue
from police but is it would we have any
powers to prevent that landlord
commercially continuing as a landlord
having these properties could we if it's
been links to actually repeated cases
where he's been linked to criminal
activities could we not prevent that
person having these properties in the
first space of War taking some action to
protect those properties from musical
activities there are Banning older
powers that are contained within this
legislation so there is the power to ban
someone from operating
um
a business to rent property but they're
really quite extreme
um they have been used for those types
of behavior in other authorities and
that's quite correct we do have those
Powers available should something like
that happen in this area they normally
only happen really where someone has
been previously convicted for a number
of offenses already and they're
continuing criminal type of behavior and
you have to go to a property Tribune or
improve your case
and ask for a Banning order that can be
issued by the property tribunal yeah
I mean I'll protecting this area we are
aware that there is certain uh criminal
activity related to things like modern
slavery and um uh other types of
criminal behaviors we are aware of that
we do work with the police but they are
they are quite
few and far between generally there
isn't a massive you know this is a a a a
a real there isn't a real problem with
private rented accommodation across the
two boroughs in terms of stress and real
um
need to take action against
non-compliant landlords generally you
know that's my general feeling but
clearly we do need these powers in case
we come across more serious um quite
serious activity
but my final work wanted to be uh I've
gone two extremes there but one of the B
of A
um
sensitive one is whereas issues where
those properties that earned
hoarding of the tenants right
um how would this be would it be down to
the landlord for not clearing the if
there's a issue it could be a fire risk
or cause an obstruction would this be
down to the landlord for not clearing
via Hazard and allowing it so we
continue would it be a civil issue where
the tenant would likely be evicted and
then who's who who'd be responsible to
their housing well also being a health
mental health issue would there be other
how would that be
how would that be implied to it however
in would a preventation from actually
further hoarding the um
looks into so I don't mean to pass the
buck on that but sorry my my team those
uh hoarding and that type of behavior
that can lead to some filthy and
verminist type issues and say often
safeguarding but dealing with vulnerable
people
um that's not part of these powers under
the housing act because you've dealt
with under Public Health legislation but
and my team don't really deal with that
deal with that directly but we do work
with our Environmental Protection Team
to deal with um quite vulnerable people
in terms of checking their kind of
Housing and you mentioned the fire
safety element of that so we would we
often get called in Via Environmental
Protection Team who deal with them
ensuring that the properties main is
clean to a reasonable standard but um
often we're dealing with them
a vulnerable person there at the time
living in poor housing conditions so we
try and work through the issues with the
tenant and try and protect the tenant
really and we're often involved with
Social Services Environmental Protection
ourselves and other agencies in
um dealing with that issue so I mean in
terms of land or tenant often often it
tends to be more owner-occupied
properties that we're dealing with
rather than private rented ones because
I suppose that landlord has then got a
remedy to the situation but I haven't
personally come across many rented
see your point are you waking up thank
you um councilor Jones Osborne I wanted
to add I think to that and then I've got
Council Agency on councilor Hinton
yeah thank you Mr chairman actually one
of the roles of the Housing Solutions
teams is to work with issues such as
just been identified where there's
possibly a hoarding issue for example
which is a mental health thing because
their work is to prevent homelessness so
if that person because of their hoarding
habit is at the risk of being beingcome
homeless then that's where the Housing
Solutions team would also be working
with them to try and get that issue
resolved it's a really difficult one but
they would that is part of their role to
do that
thank you can I move on to counselor
acne on please
thank you chairman
um
is there a program of regular inspection
or private rented properties
um and to follow on from that
as a result how many Improvement notices
have we issued in the past 18 months and
how many of those have been complied
with and how many have you had to take
action on if they haven't complied with
it and do you feel that um these the
policies that you're asking us to
endorse here actually provide sufficient
deterrent for bad landlords and finally
you mentioned that there is a register
of bad landlords and I just wondered who
and how that is published and and are
they such a list for baby midsucker
so I've got the order of those questions
right uh in terms of the regular
inspections of properties no it is a
reactive service so the inspections we
carry out will be from complaints from
tenants to us in terms of inspecting
properties how many enforcement notices
I haven't got that information to hand
again similar to the previous question
around prosecutions it's it's going to
be a small number it's going to be a
handful of
is leading to further enforcement action
is this a good deterrent yes I hope so
and the deterrent is making it
easier for us to be able to take action
against those bad landlords when that
arises as an alternative to prosecutions
in terms of the register
that
think for memory as well is something
that's included in the white paper the
leveling up white paper in private
rented sector about a national
landlord's register so that may be
something that comes forward in future
legislation
sorry so the register doesn't actually
exist at the moment
I think we're talking two slightly
different things so there is already a a
Regis a register of Rogue landlords
which is on published by the central
government Department which is now the
leveling up Department
which can be accessed online I believe
so that that and
um there are also some Regional you know
some Regional
um work that some authorities have done
together to publish date data as well
um what my colleague I think is talking
about is that there are certain
proposals for Regis registering uh
landlords and giving landlord to
register to operate in the future but
they're not yet yeah there are that's a
separate issue registering someone to
operate
housing housing housing business so
that's separate to to that and that
isn't in place yet
okay so to the register that does exist
yep
um if we reviewed that register would we
find
bad landlord in our patch uh no I doubt
it because they're only really
prosecutions and defenses that have gone
to civil penalties that would be on that
on that register at the moment and we
haven't got any of those we called it
I'll just add to what my colleague said
about um
a reactive we do run a reactive service
that probably the but we do try and
Target our work as well towards areas
that we think are where we think they're
a problem so we do do this work I've
said with the Fire Authority and police
because we see that as being really
quite important and we also so that is
more proactive work along with making
sure that we have our that the
um houses in multiple occupation that we
have in both districts are are licensed
and that they
so we are aware of those and again we do
do a proactive check on those within the
five-year period of their license
because those properties are are
unlicensed by the authorities
so for example where a house has been
used for county lines and the police are
involved and I've come across a few of
those do they do they feed that back to
you so that you're aware of that
situation they they do if they're yeah
if they feel that they're we do have to
work quite closely with them because we
hold information on certain properties
that they're interested in so they
normally just they come to us for
initial
discussions if there's an enforcement
activity plan that we do work with them
directly
if need be because it's in our joint
interest to do so I mean it's
where we should be targeting that's
where the priority of our work should be
in those kind of areas really rather
than
um you know land also compliant and
and so that's that's part of our work
yes
thank you um I'm going to move on to
councilor Hinton then councilor Grandin
and then we will enter into a debate and
look at the recommendations that we have
before us so councilor Hinton thank you
Mr chairman
um a couple of points or questions
firstly you've mentioned liaison with
the police when it comes to where
criminal effects action is is taking
place Etc what other systems do you have
in place that may be used to identify
private landlords across the districts
because they don't actually have to
register unless it's a whole house of
multiple occupancy do they
that's the first question
and the second question do registered
social landlords come under this same
category because press has shown just
recently that certain registered social
landlords have been fairly negligent in
the maintenance of their properties Etc
with uh in one case fatal consequences
so do they come under it as well
foreign
so registered providers social landlords
they are subject to the Housing Act and
they are subject to all that we've
talked about here today in these
policies
um historically we have quite we've
we've because we've got a working
relationship with them we try to work
with them
um rather than taking formal action
against them but we do tend to treat
them very similarly to we to the way
that we treat private landlords although
we don't have a great deal of complexion
a great number of complaints inquiries
from social landlord tenants and these
are quite large organizations that
should be well managed and well
regulated sometimes they're not and we
do get involved and we do get involved
from time to time but um they should be
capable of managing their own housing
stock and making sure that people live
in in safe and healthy conditions
um
in terms of building up our knowledge of
landlords that are operating within
baber and mid-suffolk the piece of work
that we've done over the last 18 months
around the minimum Energy Efficiency
standards so landlords have to have an
EPC of e or better for any property that
they rent out unless there is a valid
exemption our work in terms of
determining those properties that are
4G rated and making contact and working
with those landlords has that started
the process of us building up that
information about landlords within baber
and mid-suffolk
and if a landlord decides to rent a
property out without
an efficiency efficiency rating you
wouldn't know about it would you
yes we would through
data that we're able to receive
potentially from other sources that's
where we've then as part of our me's
project made contact with those
landlords and encouraged them to obtain
the correct EPC
the
there is information available opens
data sources so zoopla right move for
example around properties that are being
rented
and they're advertised openly
we can check
we do also I mean we've got access to
things like tenancy deposit databases
and we do sometimes when we're involved
when we're considering enforcement
action look at um
things such as
um
internet some of the records that we've
got around
land registry
and ownership of properties so we do we
do bring some information together but
our services largely reactive at the
moment so we're not proactively going
out
and looking for the people that are
looking for bad landlords we
um ideally we that's something we should
be doing but we're not we're not doing
that at the moment I think perhaps we
will be doing more of that in the future
considering um
you know some of the some of the
proposals that we've got coming forward
for resourcing it looks like we might be
able to do more of that sort of work but
we're not doing very much of that at the
moment
I'm just concerned that we hear about
the dark web and there's all sorts of
other informal
ways that people
um communicate and conduct business
to see it's but you're saying that
basically until it actually is a problem
they don't tend to come largely come to
your attention
thank you um Council Grandin and then we
will start the debate
um the penalty Bans
um are they National
rates
um
because to me they actually seem quite
high if you
have one property but then get
prosecuted because the rents in Suffolk
are not very high so it seemed to me
that even the starting point
seems fairly high for
the rental rentable values of properties
in Suffolk but then again I can see you
know as a deterrent
um and the hope that you probably won't
need to use these penalties anyway I can
see you know that that's I just wondered
are these National
um rates that you get told to use in
this situation or they rates that are
specifically for our districts
so what we've done that they aren't they
aren't nationally determined and each
Council has to determine it has to make
its own policy to be able to go ahead
and use the Civil penalty
um Powers the the ranges that you've got
there we've looked at we've done some
benchmarking with other Suffolk
authorities to to see that there is a
consistency there
um in Suffolk we're not using exactly
the same as other boroughs but
um
we felt that they lie in the right area
for providing an actual deterrent to
someone because the guidance is quite
clear that you know people know people
really don't comply and it has to get to
the stage where a civil penalty is
issued there should be a financial
deterrent there and it shouldn't be
cheaper for you as a
of Rogue land or perhaps to not comply
than it should be to actually comply so
there should be a punishment element in
there I would say as I alluded to
earlier that those are starting point
and the actual fines are more likely to
lie within the ranges in the right
columns
um there but they are subject to things
like mitigation I mean there are some
things we haven't put in yet which
um
we haven't really looked at things like
perhaps um
we could look at things like um making
if someone paid early there might be a
further reduction
um
or
some other sort of similar approach
could be considered by yourself
so we would reward someone paying up and
saying yes I've made a mistake and I'm
prepared to pay the fine and that
that was to collect the fine quicker
rather than being subject to an appeal
because there is a process behind this
it's not we don't just say that's the
fine you know we do go through quite a
detailed process to arrive yes because I
presume you actually don't want to get
to this stage anyway no we don't we want
people to you good quality accommodation
for people that's really
that's true so so all of this this today
and and in future is about the ability
to be able to
have these fines as a published
disability yes rather than you actually
expecting to have to use them yeah we
don't quite right we don't um we don't
expect an enormous enforcement activity
we don't expect really any more activity
than we're doing at the moment but I
think if we do come across cases where
we really need to
um take some action what we don't want
to do is to be without these powers and
not have the ability to do what we need
to do so that's really what this is
about and the enforcement policy itself
is more about just being kind of clear
and transparent and fair and open about
kind of the work that we do and what
what people can expect about us engaging
with what Learners can expect when we
engage with them and what they should be
doing to make sure that they comply so
appendix one is more about the actual
enforcement policy and the approaches
that we take and we feel that um by
using that approach that that will help
us in if we are
if we are maybe criticized or we're told
that we're not being clear about what
we're doing it's it's all there really
we can point to that policy and saying
that this is this is quite clear about
the approach that we're taking to
towards land or
land notices and making sure
the virus
thank you very much thank you um we'll
move on to debate then and we've got
before us three recommendations which
are on page 92 so if um members could
speak to those recommendations can I
make a suggestion that
3-1 is to for us to make comment on the
new policy and recommend we perhaps we
should separate those out and however
there's 3.4 recommended cabinet that
comments made at this meeting be made
available to Cabinet when they discuss
implementing the policy
so Council Carter your first
classification bomb we moved on so um I
would say that um
I'm completely in favor of issue he's
going if the powers being in it is
Jew of course we have I mean we haven't
got the prosecution at the moment we
haven't got reinforcement going in and
this is going to be for residents for
their safety for their for benefits of
tenants for residents and benefit for
Neighbors as well not having to deal
with these the situations put in place
so
where it's got the
enforcement that's got to be we've got
we've got the stick end here rather than
just we carry it and it's um these
recommendations are I'm
personally in favor of we sir go ahead
so it's not what I was intending to say
about it but I've got in a moment
so Council are you minded to propose the
recommendations yeah I am yes thank you
very much
um do we have a second to please
council do you wish to speak
no okay does anybody wish to speak a
counselor Hinton
thank you Mr chairman um I'm just I
agree with the with the recommendations
in front of us but I'm just thinking
that perhaps an additional one on there
to encourage the
compilation of a complete register of
private landlords across the district
would help rather than waiting for
enforcement action to be taken because
it would enable a preemptive approach to
certain properties that obviously Stand
Out perhaps as being substandard in the
future so a register of private
landlords across the district which
shouldn't be that difficult to assemble
bearing in mind that within the key
information it talks about us having
privately rented sector which accounts
for 17 of the housing stock in the
district well if we know it's 17 percent
it shouldn't be too difficult for us to
to produce a list of them so that we can
then effectively keep an eye on them
rather than waiting for something to go
wrong in the first place that would be
my only suggestion as an addition
so here's the hint of are you content
that we include that as one of the
comments that's made at the meeting
which is made available yeah so that
would be included so
does anybody else wish to speak does
anybody cancel AP young and then cancel
the scarf
how is the 17 arrival
of course
I mean I mean that that is a that is a a
rough figure of what we picked up from a
housing strategy we haven't done stock
ing surveys it's not a it's not
something that we have the ability to do
at the moment but it's um based on I
think housing strategy information that
comes from census data and it's roughly
what we feel the
um that sector looks like at the moment
in terms of the figure so it's yeah I
a
point from um councilor Hinton there in
that
um I I'm a little bit concerned that if
we do start compiling registers of
people we can't really put them in the
public domain because there's going to
be some sensitivity issues around
protecting people's private information
so I I'll just raise that as an issue
for consideration but
yeah as an internal as an internal
mechanism that really helps that's fine
thank you
to the to the register Point around
um we are aware that this is potentially
coming through central government
through statute so that would be my
preferred
choice in terms of compiling or holding
a register but that is supported by
national legislation and guidance for
its operation
thank you Council scarf
you know Justin for that because I I
think actually we need to wait for the
statutory need to register for uh
homeowners or landlords to rent because
there is there a lot of private
Arrangements between an individual who
don't even use a letting agency or
anything
so you know there are some difficulties
including that information and of course
it always changes
has you know could be so just want to
point out on page 103
um you've got two 3.68 work in default
page 103 you've got two is repeated to a
price 3.68 in the work in default so you
just need to amend the policy before you
adopt the policy
thank you well spotted and we will
update that thank you
right thank you so are you all content
that we go to the vote do you want me to
read it all out again are you happy
um okay so I will ask the governance
officer to
carry out the electronic vote
[Music]
buys
added the comment or we've had the
recommendation that comments made at
this meeting be made available to
Cabinet when they discuss implementing
the policy so
yeah
so
do you want to do are you happy to vote
as it's on the screen and we'll add that
in
okay
can I take your vote verbally
thank you chair that is 11 votes for so
that is unanimous thank you very much
um we just need a couple of minutes not
time to escape
um because there is a short presentation
I believe
um and we need to load that that up
right members we go to resume now with
agenda item 11. which is an information
bulletin a skills overview and update
this is for noting so we've got a short
presentation and there could be a period
of questions but there are no
recommendations or decisions needed to
be taken at the end
thank you
so can I hand over to the officers
please
thank you and we've tried to keep the
presentation as as short as possible we
know that you're um you've had a very
long morning
um but we obviously take questions if
you have any at the end
and just oh yes it is the dinaro
um so just as a way of background what
we are bringing to you this morning is
an update on where we currently are in
terms of the progress against delivery
of the skills actions that have been
um included within the recovery plan
that we published we drafted during 2021
but published in early 2022. that set
out the challenges that the economy was
going to face
during and after the covert pandemic the
framework that we set out for the
recovery plan was to split our programs
of work into three areas Innovative and
creative connected and sustainable and
successful and skilled and within three
time frames for activity react which was
very short term three to six month
activity recover was um six to 12 months
and regrow was two to three years
just to give you a flavor in terms of
the skilled and successful
um program area we've split up
of course
is that any better yeah I'm afraid I
can't I can't read anything on the
screen either we can share the
presentation with the detail okay
thank you yeah
um so in terms of the recovery and
regrow actions these are all published
within the recovery plan and the
strategy that was published in early
2022 so this is only an update in terms
of the
refresher if you like in terms of the
specific actions around successful and
skilled items
um
we just to pick out a few of those under
the recovery area we looked at focusing
on the development of an innovation and
Skills Center for Gateway 14 supporting
and raising aspiration in partnership
with schools and the creation of a
skills Innovation program
um supporting the cultural groups to
um uh in support development and drive
people back into the China centers and
an economies through healthier lives
program to engage with primary school
children
in terms of regrow which is a longer
term ambition we're looking at as a
promotion of aspiration across the
district
offering opportunities for all ages to
gain stronger transferable skills
through partnership working with
business and education
um
looking at joining National forums and
round tables to be at the Forefront of
information and learning about how to
stimulate growth and successfully defeat
our challenges
so in terms of the specific role that
we've got we'll pass on to Claire for
some of this
there we go
um yes so what's our role as a district
council obviously we have no statutory
role for example in education however
our strong aspirations for our
communities and our strong need for our
healthy economy means that we continue
to work in this area and it ties in with
all of our priorities
we work hard to ensure that our
communities are visible and represented
baber and mid-suffolk can disappear a
little bit in some of those broader
Landscapes of the DWP and the education
because their their geographies and
boundaries don't follow our own so we
make sure that we are very well
represented and visible and vocal in
wider groups and networks we
in identifying the kind of the support
and delivery of others working with
private providers third third sector
organizations and statutory providers to
make sure that the the best delivery
that's available is brought to our
communities because that's another area
where we have to ensure that our
communities are represented we don't
have the big towns and the obvious areas
of need so we always have to make it
easy for those deliverers to be in our
patches
then obviously creating additionality by
adding value with uh small amounts of
funding or accommodation or whatever
activity we can to make sure that the
delivery is is encouraged and avoiding
duplication there's a lot of funded
programs out there that all do very
similar things so being part of networks
and encouraging our providers to work
together to complement each other's
delivery rather than everybody trying to
deliver the same thing
the external skills picture is massive
there is a link in this presentation
which takes you to some of the national
employment programs that are on that
that are available it's ever changing
um it's huge and it's very complicated
for people to navigate but we um
we try and stay in touch with as much of
that as we can so that we know what's
happening and make sure that some of
it's happening across our area
the county and lepwide projects again
there are many of them and again we have
to make sure that they don't focus in
areas of great needs such as just
lowestoft and Ipswich but that they are
those are represented in Barbara
mid-suffolk as well
um locally you've got the community
adult education budget that enables
people to deliver skills training and
support across various parts mainly
Stone Market and Sudbury if I'm honest
that's when most of it happens we've got
independent training providers local
colleges again we suffer because we
don't have an independent Fe College so
we encourage where possible access to
college and and support people to access
colleges throughout our district
age targeted provision sorry
I'm sorry I thought someone was asking
me something
um and then third sector precision
provision and District neat schemes
which is for those not in education
employment or training
so what's coming next
um
there are a lot of anticipated
challenges coming our young people are
struggling massively off the back of
covid we've had a huge increase in for
example in Suffolk young people being
excluded from year 10 and 11 an increase
in free School Meal provision and
increase in elective home education
and a 23 increase in school
young people disengaging from school
all of those we know will have an
ongoing impact on our young people the
business support landscape is changing
so obviously the changes in European
funding will impact on how current
business support programs are delivered
there's uh still an ongoing conversation
about what the lap will look like going
forwards and how the growth Hub
provision will work
um
recently the new technical skills Legacy
report that was commissioned by the
Suffolk growth program board has just
been completed it was done a couple of
years ago and it's just been revised
that identifies and anticipated spend in
excess of 70 billion pounds just on
infrastructure products in Norfolk and
Suffolk alone over the next 17 years
whilst that can be seen as an
opportunity
it also has some ongoing risks to our
existing businesses we've got some big
providers coming in building big
schemes that will need to recruit
locally so we need to help our local
businesses to be resilient to that
um
then of course the changing programs of
funding County D or UK shared Prosperity
funds the loss of uh EU funding all of
these are things that we're working
towards and and being engaged with to
ensure that those remain benefit to our
districts as much as possible and then
of course there's a lot that we don't
know nobody saw covid coming brexit is
still the impact of that is still
playing out as well as you know changing
economic pictures in wider European
countries so all of those things we have
to be responsive to and flexible and
that in our recovery program is is how
we're trying to work to enable ourselves
to be response to what we know is going
on and also react and support the new
challenges as they happen
this is just some of the stuff we're
doing currently
um oh hang on I've lost my slide myself
I can't read what's on the screen and I
can't remember what's in front of me
there we go thank you again as I said
supporting and engaging with local
networks
um we have worked using the UK shared
Prosperity funds we've commissioned
jointly with Ipswich Borough and West
Suffolk Council a program of support
that is dedicated to those young people
most vulnerable uh at the loss of the EU
funding from the employment support
um it's it's a particular piece of
commissioning that I'm really pleased
with and was enabled largely by the Boba
mid-suffolk legal and procurement teams
working to support our other districts
as well so that we could make this
happen
um we've got the new business sites
coming on uh at Hadley cross street and
cross street I we've just worked with
some of our local schools to trial a
pilot youth Enterprise challenge which
in the schools that have taken it up has
been really positive but it's provided
us certainly with a lot of learning but
it's also enabled us to develop our
relationships with our secondary schools
a bit better
Gateway 14 Innovation and Skills Center
Michelle's already mentioned a skills
strategy that's been developed as part
of the free wider Freeport East program
which should be really significant for
both of our districts in working with
those businesses that come into Freeport
East and how they will provide skill
support to our communities the innovate
to elevate program which is a really
quite interesting program which takes
the concept of the knowledge transfer
partnership and makes it available to
those businesses that are so important
to our district eight to nine percent of
our businesses employ less than 10
people and and many of those businesses
wouldn't even have the opportunity or
maybe it wouldn't even occur to them to
try and engage with higher education as
a way to develop their processes and the
way they work going forwards and the
innovate to elevate program will really
demonstrate the value of that then
the employment Land review and Retail
Town Center study that we will be
working with our planning policy
colleagues to develop will obviously
have quite a significant impact going
forwards to the districts in the coming
years and then engaging with the
infrastructure and large development
schemes to try and raise the
um
profile of skills and the need to use
those big developments to add value to
the skills arena in our districts
so what's still to do well there's
always lots to do
we want to transition from a delivery
against a recovery plan you know
recognize that we're moving on from
where we were a couple of years and
actually turn that into a proper
strategy or a formal strategy that sets
out some clear Ambitions for the
medium-term future
the ongoing work is
um
UK SPF has provided us with some
opportunities that we will look to
develop over the next couple of years
across both communities and economic
acting
active um closer working with our
statutory partners and others you know
we can't do it on our own so we need to
make sure that we work with those
statutory Partners to encourage the best
value for our districts
and then
carry on you know working with
developers developments to ensure that
employment skills remains a high profile
thing and working with our schools and
education providers as much as we can to
develop our understanding of their many
challenges
and then finally really what we need to
continue doing what we do and to do it
better is we need that support and
connection and relationships so your
Insight as our community
members is so important to us your
relationships with businesses your
relationships with schools your
relationships with those business
networks really helps us because we we
have you know in excess of 9000
businesses across baber and mid-suffolk
we can't possibly know them all as well
as they need so your Insight is really
valuable to us as we go forwards
thank you thank you very much do we have
any questions
Casa Carta
uh just quickly um we've mentioned on
the impact of covid and also schools one
thing we haven't commented on is
actually the impact on send schooling uh
covert has been particularly difficult
for a child with additional
needs Suffolk is currently one of the
worst performing for send supports uh
God's ehp and things like that we have
people parents who are unable to work
having to leave their Employments to
care for children because we're not able
to find educational places for them
we really do need to take up the county
is failing the areas failing if we can
do something to support these needs and
we're better to get free up some
employment for up to people for
employment and also help children who
are suffering and possibly aid for them
so she transition and be able to go into
employment sales future which currently
we're not going to be not in position to
that's all I want to say about that
yes if there is a response yes please do
this is these are all you you're quite
correct
um but what we are doing through our
relationship with Suffolk County Council
like I said we we don't have a statutory
uh responsibility for education but
we're working very closely with Suffolk
County Council to raise
um amongst others those people that have
significant barriers and that was part
of the reasoning behind the
commissioning of the uh the Youth
Employment Program for those young
people with significant barriers many of
those will have ehcp plans uh be
children leaving care and and that's a
real Focus for that program
um
um there's also a program at County uh
looking at sort of more intensive
support for children with ehcp plans
around work experience work
opportunities and local
things and and they have actually asked
the district councils to be involved in
those conversations so absolutely it's
something that we're aware of and where
we where we can absolutely using our
relationship
those
schemes
thank you
um I've got councilor egg p young and
then councilor Grandin
cancel that thing on please thank you Mr
German
um I'm particularly interested in how we
are going to be able to encourage
um
young people of working age to engage in
our high-tech Industries because that's
one of our strategic focuses uh in in
the district what with Freeport is
Gateway Fortune Etc and it seems to me
that actually you know there are plenty
of job opportunities there but
absolutely a complete lack of a skilled
labor force to address it
is it what what's the sort of approach
here and I know it's not just us on our
own but you know it seems to me that
that got to be one
channel of
work that needs to be progressed at a
fairly rapid rate or not
struggling with the technology sorry
they I made those skills programs don't
I I can't even manage two buttons
um so yeah there are some digital skills
pathway programs that are ongoing in
Suffolk
um and it's been interesting actually
because a lot of the digital skills
provision across Suffolk has had a
pretty low uptake from businesses where
it's been offered and we have offered a
couple of sessions through our curiosity
careers program around digital skills
that haven't had a huge amount of
interest from young people so I think
um for me for us it's reflecting on
actually how we're communicating that
and what we're offering whereas uh when
we offered games Industry Program and
film industry there was a massive
interest in it but that of course is
very and also the digital creative and
marketing Pro program that we did
through our careers program that also
had a really strong interest so I think
it's about the language we use when we
address young people with some of this
so it's kind of an ongoing thing for me
and an area that I need to
put more focus into and make sure that
the the skill support that is out there
is is is sorry you well
um
so you know for me the digital skills is
just a base element really in terms of
the workplace I'm much more interested
to see where we're going with more
technical skills because you know the
sorts of businesses that we're trying to
attract to the district and the region
requires significant engineering skills
and technical skills and I don't think
that we have good provision in our areas
for that
and yes so probably the largest area of
focus that we have at the moment is
around the Gateway 14 skills and
Innovation Center so we've been working
really closely
um not just with Gateway 14 but also
with
um a variety of other partners who are
kind of we formed a sort of uh external
project group if you like with West
Suffolk college and both University of
Suffolk and University of Essex and what
we are seeking to do
um as part of the business case is is
um pull together a program of bringing
technical businesses or businesses using
technology and particularly High
performing high growth businesses much
closer to people who who perhaps are
interested in those areas or even aren't
even interested but want to upskill so
that's exactly where a lot of our energy
has been going over the over the last
few months is pulling together the
evidence base so that we can start
hopefully if that particular Center goes
ahead we can start to really make a
difference in terms of
um connecting local people with those
those High skill roles and giving them
the skills to to enable them to take up
those roles so that's kind of been the
focus over that over the last few months
and
yes Michelle if I can just add as well
the um alongside the Practical the and
some of the locations specific we've
been working with the Freeport East
Partners Over The Wider skills um
ambition piece which is looking at how
we can raise aspiration and provide
inspiration for young people to engage
with Industries like the higher tax or
the ambition behind the Freeport East
skills plan is to attract high value
High skilled jobs but to create the
level of ambition and aspiration within
young people to be able to understand
what jobs are available locally what
industries those careers are in and how
what the career path they need to take
in order to be able to access some of
those roles so what
um courses they need to take what what
subjects they need to choose at GCSE
level if they want to progress in
certain career paths so there's lots of
different ways that we're trying to
tackle one very specific issue and as
Claire mentioned earlier we've been
working with the Suffolk growth Partners
on a technical skills Legacy report
which is covered in the Hall of Suffolk
looking at that wider ambition piece for
the types of jobs that are going to be
created through some of the major
infrastructure programs and what we need
to be doing now with the education
Partners in order to be able to get
people ready for for getting access to
those jobs
thank you
um councilor Grandin
um so this isn't a criticism
um you know I did see on the avoid
duplication
um
and obviously county is the area that
provides education and skills and so on
I just wonder have should we be doing
this it's lovely that we are in laudable
that we are
but as we
you know it's very
we're a very busy organization it's
difficult doing all the things that we
have to do statute statutorially
um should we be doing all these lovely
extras
um that I think are very nice to do but
when there's County that is prescribed
to do that why why are we doing this
um it's nice but should we be when we
haven't got the funds and so on thanks
Fiona I'm itching to come in on that one
um so so there's there's a few things to
answer that one is that
um
you know even those skills funding is
administered at a county-wide level
um number one there's not enough funding
to do all the things that need to be
done
um almost secondary to whether it's a
statutory service for the council there
are things out there the kind of things
that we've been talking about which
which need to be done that are not being
done through centralized skills funding
at the moment although there's an
interesting question about what
Devolution might bring
um but secondly
um I think the government have
recognized that the old the old approach
which is uh centralized skills funding
that gets fed into one or two
organizations hasn't been as successful
as it could have been and it's much more
effective if you get a range of local
Partners
um each playing a role in that and I
guess that's really sums up Claire's
presentation which is we play a role in
it
um we're certainly not
um we're not trying to take it away from
the County Council and you're right we
don't have the kind of level of funding
um but it is important that that local
partners are key to part of that
delivery and like I say that's been
recognized at a government level because
um there's no better people to to be
closer to their communities and the
people are involved in those communities
so that's where our our role comes in
really and
Michelle do you want to pick that up
yeah sorry I was just flagging up we've
literally wild Fiona has been given that
update we've had an email from the head
of skills at Suffolk County Council
asking for our specific feedback and
advice on a on a particular piece of
curriculum development for some of the
colleges particularly around 16 to 19
Learners apprentices those not an
education employment or training adults
returning to learning and part-time
Learners in employment and they're
looking specifically for economic
priorities you'd like the colleges to be
focused on as well as any particular
place based or sector-specific
challenges so what we're not doing is
duplicating what the kind of council are
doing what we're doing is adding value
to the work that the county are doing
with their um mandatory activity and
then filling some of the gaps in where
they aren't able to deliver so
particularly around the shared
Prosperity fund that money has been
given to the district council to manage
we've chosen to work with the County
Council and other local authorities in
order to be able to get best value and
provide the best service for our for our
residents and businesses
we see this as a whole system that works
together as opposed to each of us
individually competing to provide
services
thank you councilor Hinton
the first word I would say is
apprenticeships because they seem to be
in more demand from youngsters nowadays
than University places or anything else
and when you look at uh let's face it
the University of Suffolk where the
degree course in hairdressing management
and football coaching I'll be sort of
something to set you up for life in a
high a high paid industry but what about
the offshore wind and the Alternative
Energy in this stream because there's a
dirty great big offshore wind farms that
require all sorts of people we've got
regular reports about shortages of
ground of air source heat pump Engineers
installation Engineers there's 30 000 or
something required to help install those
all of the green targets at central
government has thrown about the place
but there's no support to actually put
it in place and implement it and also
what we work uh how are we working with
organizations just across the border I'm
always going on about this there's a
there is no Iron Curtain along the river
store uh you can actually cross over it
and we should be working more with the
Colchester Institute and the various
organizations connected with Essex
University where of course that is a
Center of Excellence for robotics
which is obviously a very much a
high-tech type sort of industry but also
to bear in mind that Freeport East
covers Harwich as well as Felix though
it's not just all Gateway 14.
so you're absolutely right and my answer
was going to be Freeport gives us some
real opportunities to look at skills
Michelle's already at outline Michelle
was actually the lead on on the skill
stuff for across the whole of the
Freeport area and and it does stretch
into into Harwich and um but also we've
been working closely with people like
Colchester Institute
um and the University of Essex the
University of Essex are actually our
partner on the innovate to elevate
scheme and because we recognize their
skills and expertise in certain areas of
of Technology Etc and so there's lots of
work going on around Freeport and I
think over the next year you'll see more
hopefully more Project work coming out
of of Freeport just across baber and
mid-suffolk it isn't just around the tax
sites it's very much around the two
districts
um to answer the other part of your
question
um and I'll leave one of my colleagues
to come in around apprenticeships But to
answer the other part around you know
the big opportunities around things like
offshore and I'd argue it's actually
unsure as well uh so there's a you know
putting heat pumps in every home
eventually is going to require more
skills in that area and some of that
we're looking at as I've said earlier
around the Gateway 14 skills and
Innovation uh Center but we're also
working with the colleges uh we're
working with Suffolk County Council who
as you heard have commissioned through
Suffolk growth this technical
skills Legacy report you know
big infrastructure projects coming
forward they need all of us to work
together all of our all of the agencies
and districts to work together to ensure
that we have a proper plan to deliver
the skills for the future because
otherwise we'll find ourselves with a
whole bunch of infrastructure projects
coming forward that we just can't
service or we're bringing people in from
other parts of the UK and that and that
can't be right what I would say though
is that piece of work Starts Now in our
primary schools because as Claire said
earlier and you have to get people on a
sort of track to to even get them
attracted or interested or aspiring to
certain sectors or certain industries
and to start when when somebody is 15 or
16 is too late so quite a lot of the
work we're going to be looking at is
working with primary schools and how we
can and and certainly the Curiosity
program although it was a little bit
older it was early Secondary School it
was all about giving people a taste of
those Industries and what they might
involve so I think it is a rich tapestry
we probably haven't covered it all this
morning but working in Partnership is
the key I don't know if someone wanted
to mention apprenticeships
so apprenticeships is an interesting one
and I was a
recruitment Fair on Friday and Hadley
the the MP had organized and I had lots
of really interesting conversations with
some young people and their families and
also parents who were kind of
disappointed with the experience that
young people were having at University
and concern around where it would leave
them and I think apprenticeships is
becoming a higher and more prominent
Focus for many of our young people but
not just young people actually people
already in work are taking advantage of
their employers apprenticeship Levy
contribution to actually engage with
apprenticeships as older people and
people that are actually in work so
apprenticeships took a massive knock
during covid and it's taken a while to
recover from that and baber is now at
the point where it's got six percent
higher level apprenticeships in place
than there was prior to covert
mid-suffolk is a little bit down at six
percent it's still six percent below but
what's interesting is that both
districts have seen an increase in
intermediate and higher level
apprenticeships that are being taken up
since before covert
big where the big gap in apprenticeships
has come is the level two so what would
be a traditionally 16 year old
apprenticeship the apprenticeship uptake
is seems to be kicking in post 18 but
they are recovering and they are
certainly becoming a more prominent and
popular choice of qualification for for
people both entering the workplace and
actually for those already in it
all right thank you thank you very much
thank you members
um thanks for your presentation thank
you for answering all our questions
members the information brought it in is
for noting
um and we do need to move on rapidly
onto item 12 which is the forthcoming
decisions list
do members have any comments to make on
that
if not well then that also is
for noting the forthcoming decisions
list is for noting
does anyone have any comments on the
um
excuse me committee tracker the action
tracker
that being the case the overview and
screw to the action track is for noting
we have the baber overview excretory
work plan
that is also for noting
and the mid-suffolk overview and
security work plan that also is for
noting and that concludes the business
of this meeting at 13 20.